que le plus forts l'emportent et encore
quatre heures encore quatre heures de
match
c'est pourquoi pourquoi attendait la
caméra qu'est ce qui lui arrive et on
avait réglé le problème pour plus que ça
fasse de flou ça va on a juste le temps
avant ouais c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
il sait il s'est réinventé une life la
cam elle s'est inventé une life avec la
mise au point ça a été réglé je vérifier
que live soit bien parti
je vais ainsi que là il soit bien parti
alors oui ce qui l'est ce live
ou est ce qu'il est
on va voir avec le chat en fait j'ai eu
la notification j'aime bien vérifier je
n'ai pas fait d'erreur
je vérifie que j'ai pas fait d'erreur
attendez je le vois en ligne et j'arrive
pas vraiment là say say say say j'ai
réussi à le stopper
j'ai réussi à le chopper donc les
joueurs sont pas là ils sont déjà en
retard c'est terrible hop
non c'est pas
c'est pas partie pendant un message
on va voir le match tu vas bientôt
partir et moi j'annonce un massacre
dennis al sarine
j'ai pris de l'âge prend live juste à
l'heure pour pour que ça démarre quoi
salut série 5 ou 10 nov
là après je peux pas y faire grand chose
quand ça démarre pas bon ça démarre en
retard on sait pas trop pourquoi on va
s'unir à la sarine j'annonce un massacre
de la part de niall parce que smirnov
qui joue de nuit donc mon avis il va il
va tenir une petite heure et puis après
il va craquer tout d'un coup un peu
comme la dernière fois sauf qu'alain
fois joué contre ça doit ni et donc ça
pouvait encore résister ni à le grand
favori ouais ouais ce serait deux jours
pour smirnov je dirais pas mais l'a pas
déjà sarine est favori je veux dire mais
je dirais ok il a de bonnes chances de
gagner mais là là c'est énorme c'est
hulot chess salut overflow merci de
venir les gars n'hésitez pas à parler de
choses et d'autres un an le chat si vous
souhaitez ça m'occupera ça m'occupera ce
que je veux dire qu'aujourd'hui c'était
pas la grosse motive pour venir vous
commentez le match pour rien vous cacher
on peut dire que c'était pas je suis pas
je suis pas je suis pas venu je suis pas
venu sur l'ordi avec le grand sourire
fend venir commenter ce match 5 1 on a
beaucoup quoi certains moments jamais on
peut récupérer là le week end quand il y
avait une petite coupure avec les
speechs à ce mes mais là quand c'est le
troisième match déjà dans la semaine ça
il fait simple quand la semaine dernière
quoi troisièmes quatrièmes ils font mal
c'est à l'impression que c'est comme le
tour de france c'est tata d'école
première catégorie tu as un deuxième col
de première catégorie et là tout d'un
coup de ses tarifs sur le hors catégorie
il ya quand même des passages à 12 13%
qui font mal l'étape était longue et
demain demain je pense qu'on finit sur
l'ascension là il s'appelait c'était pas
le port de balès c'était ces tests etc à
l'ascension avec les passages à 24 25 %
où il y avait les coureurs qui passe en
diagonale pour être celui de demain
c'est un peu ça tu vois et après demi
finales finale tu enchaînes avec le giro
tu vois ta ta ta déjà pris le tour de
france est atteinte en chêne giraud
directement après les champs elysées un
pronostic victoire très facile de niall
sarine aujourd'hui à bobby fischer 2
pour répondre à ta question
pas de bluff pas de bluff
donc ces petites structures carlsbad un
ici un peu plus sympa pour les blancs le
placement qui s est légèrement
supérieure mais mais ça se joue
ouais mais là c'est la planche des
belles filles mais pas après un
contre-la-montre de 28km quoi après un
effort solitaire de 140 km
non franchement
franchement ça qu'il ya beaucoup de
matches qu'on va pas on va pas se le
cacher c'est plus long qu roland garros
inscription crauland garros a sera un
petit peu comme comme si on passait un
mois de roland garros juniors avant le
roland garros adultes quoi histoire
d'être bien sûr je m'en amuse c'est le
plus important
avec le sourire avec le soir comme je
vous ai dit avec le sourire aujourd'hui
quand même a le sourire est de mise
autour des 1 et va essayer de percer au
centre un jour ou l'autre il va se
placer les noirs si vous c'est ça qui se
retrouve avec un pion isolant des cinq
qui va faire tourner 8 d'accord pourquoi
pas flash de il va préparer peut-être un
cavalier 5 et f4 de4 peuvent être
jouable aussi les blancs ils ont tous
les plans en fait la queue dans ta quasi
envie de faire tout reif 8 tours 8 bon
j'exagère un peu mais oui il replace ces
pièces mais il n'a pas vraiment de plan
qui est le favori niall sarine et énorme
favori
et quand je dis énorme favori c'est
j'attends un écart minimum de +6 points
prennent avantage c'est que plus l'écart
sera fait rapidement - moins longtemps
genre à commenter le match donc vu qu'on
connaît plus ou moins le vainqueur déjà
on va moi je vais je vais être à fond
pour sarine en fait cavalier e deux
cavaliers f4 peut être un plan aussi et
salue bioman qu'une
tours c'est un pour replacer la tour
peut être un coup aussi
qui a les blancs et qui a les noirs
alors pour faire simple à écrire le nom
juste en dessous en fête et au dessus de
l'échiquier du coup ce terrain pour
faire simple on a écrit juste au dessus
des dents en aminian antoine smirnov là
du coup génial sarine côté blanc on
s'est dit on va mettre les noms dans le
bon ordre
il ya eu une hésitation à un moment
donné on s'est dit et ce qu'on a
interverti les noms mais aux joueurs qui
allaient blanc au dessus le joueur qui a
les blancs en dessous histoire de de
piéger tout le monde mais après on s'est
dit non on va on va écrire le nom au
dessus et en dessous pour que ça
corresponde salut baron second soir les
joueurs du speed boeing chess c'est
terrible c'est hype tard zolder salut
sinon ouais
comment on peut dire que le tournoi fait
le format de tournoi fait l'unanimité
c'est déjà ça ça reste complexe on va
écrire la couleur du texte en blanc ah
ouais on n'aura pas ce soit plus vivre
et c'est pas faut qu ils offs avec
classe et pas à pas assez explicite
alors attendez j'ai oublié de mettre le
chrono du coup on va dire qu'il reste 26
mai à deux plutôt resté 29 24 en fait
j'ai envoyé le chrono après je sais pas
c'était boring guerre le match était
serré après pour moi en fait vu la
longueur des matches c'est tout le temps
boring mai mais après je ne sais pas si
côté spectateurs c'était intéressant
pour moi dans tous les cas c'est trop
long même quand les matches sont serrés
après après peut-être pour les
spectateurs comme ils peuvent partir et
revenir c'était peut être sympa la fin à
baron seront peut-être quand tu peux
partir et revenir que pour la fin
c'était cool après le truc c'est que
quand tu es quand tu es devant le match
en fait tout le monde que tu te
projettes sur un truc qui dure quatre
heures même s'il a des ailes la dernière
année dernière 25 minutes sont cool en
fait comme tu as déjà passé trois heures
et demi devant ça reste boring aussi
quoi mais à mais peut-être que peut-être
que pour les spectateurs du coup c'est
différent parce que tu viens que pour la
fin après faut aimer le bullet 1 parce
que c'est le seul moment intéressant
aussi
ça te regarde une étape de plaine du
tour de france de 230 kilomètres c'est
ça ou du coup l'intéressant c'est pas un
peu comme une étape de plaine les trois
derniers kilomètres
donc pour le gars qui allume sa télé à
5,5 10 km de la fin qui regardent le
train et où l'état peut paraître cool
après pour le gars qui reste depuis le
moment du départ jusqu'à l'arrivée
franchement tt tt j'espère juste que ça
arrive en fait donc c'est dur à dire la
même chose avec un format cette serait
beaucoup plus intéressant mais bon ils
sont pas encore arrivés peut-être dans 8
10 ans il y aura une tentative donc là
les blancs restent toujours mieux à ce
que je vous disais c'est les blancs qui
ont les plans et les ruptures les idées
de f34 lecavalier a eu 5 après les noirs
ils sont un peu en contre donc ça peut
très bien tourner côté noir
ça peut très bien tourné
et salue velociraptor x donc il a pris
le fou et tour cinq coups sur ses 5 puis
on prend il y aura pas de cavalier
prendre ce qui a fait 5 qui fera une
enfilade
donc fait tour c1 il s'en prend la
colonne c
et là la paire de fou donc il va pousser
un moment donné au centre il maintient
la tension pour le moment près il est
mal autant niall alors il ya une erreur
de connexion mais les côté serveur ou de
mon côté alors c'est moi qui ai un
problème de connexion avec le serveur ou
là c'est moi qui avais prem de connexion
avec le serveur tchatche com
mais ma connexion fonctionne puisque
j'ai zoom ouvert et j'ai le stream
ouvert donc c'est vraiment un problème
de connexion aux serveurs j'ai
l'impression que ça n'affecte pas les
joueurs pour le moment et c'est bien là
le plus important
mais c'est des gros soucis
combien de coups un joueur d'échecs mais
imaginons sa tête lorsqu'il joue ça peut
aller un joueur pro sur les positions ça
va deux trois quatre coups après ce peut
même aller jusqu'à une quinzaine 15 20
suivant les positions donc là on a on a
raté un les quelques puissants et ganges
rap mais ce qu'on peut voir c'est que du
coup les blancs la paire de fou ya le
pion isolé pour les noirs donc
maintenant c'est un avantage stable pour
les blancs mais un petit problème de
pendule et salue antonymes
pressée de prissé de il va je pensais
qu'il allait tenter un des quatre
peut-être même sa dé perdre un pion
halal car il peut revenir en d4 adamence
et c'est toi c'est vraiment un avantage
stable pour pour nihal mais bon avec six
secondes sur la pendule est du coup il
s'est fait enfermer le fou et il a
pourri son avantage bien joué de la part
d'antoine et maintenant il ya plus
davantage parce qu'il ya une plus on
fait avec ce fou prend 1,4 qu'il était
obligé de faire il a perdu et
l'avantagent de la paire de fou et les
avantages du pion isolé qu il a perdu
ses deux avantages en un seul coup et
maintenant le pion il est isolé mais il
est surtout passé parce qu'il ya plus le
pion aux oeufs pour le bloquer donc ce
pion il va avancer et maintenant il va
falloir essayer de lui faire passer la
dernière étape
si on pouvait le protéger avec le fou ce
serait excellent et là faut calculer fou
prend b4 tourbe et un tour c'est un
pardon way qui doit marcher donc les
blancs doit faire 4 pour empêcher tour
s'est injustement et préparez-vous
prendre des deux qui est joué maintenant
fou prend des deux tours prend des deux
dames c'est un échange rouages deux
tours c4 f3 et tour à quatre alors la
tour qui est bien placé mais cette
finale elle peut pas être gagnante leroy
qui va à je pensais qu'ils allaient
mettre leur ont eu cinq quand même ça
donne quand même envie de monter ce roi
et repartir vers des quatre c4 la petite
voie lactée
le pion qui va venir en a 5 c'est
logique mais le roi qui va venir un peu
chapeauté tout ça il se fait couper par
est tombé de ici logique ça va échanger
en b
la tour qui va venir en a deux et le roi
qui va peut-être revenir comme ça pour
faire un perpétuel
alors il va échanger prendre g2 il va
s'en prendre à h 4 arrive à gagner h4
quand même ayvaz allag qu'elle doit être
nul mais avec peu de temps elle peut se
gagner à la cipr ans il va faire froid
prend à faut jouer plus vite la niall et
aux 5,6 allez olla là il avait avec à
une seconde c'est dur faut pas qu'ils
tombent la leaf aux profonds représ
mouffe à et c'est les noirs qui tombe
quelle catastrophe il s'est endormi il
s'est endormi ou problèmes de connexion
là parce que c'est quand même sévère de
tomber dans cette position avec les nord
avec une secondes par coup c'est très
très jeune c'est rarissime franchement
là j'ai envie de dire on tonnes bon
c'est vrai il à chuck après comme je dis
ainsi joue de nuit franchement dépassé
les minuit 1h du mat ça arrive de
s'éteindre comme ça un petit peu assez
quand même étonnant parce qu'il avait un
pion de plus ils pouvaient près move
très facilement mais c'est une défaite
qui pourrait coûter cher puisque c'est
vrai qu'il est pas favori du match s'ils
commencent à perdre celle qui doit
gagner ou en tout cas pressé
donc là c'est un petit problème côté
entonne ne faudrait pas que cette
mésaventure se reproduise
alors
n'attendez faut que je baninga jeu déjà
revenir temporairement je suis pas un
cherchera à comprendre plus tard
bon attention ne pas se prendre un foot
français 5 points dames français 5
parce que sinon on fait un nom courant
russie ouais c'est un nom assez courant
et et anton est un prénom assez courant
aussi des six des cinq si ça peut être
une idée pour prendre le centre pas
reprendre le centre pour contrer le
centre parce qu'à l'heure actuelle c'est
les blancs qui ont un pion plus au
centre entre guillemets le pion des six
participants un peu moins au jeu
centrale donc venir faire des 5 pour les
changer et faire briller le fou en
batterie avec la dame est assez logique
ou même le cavalier un d'ailleurs et
s'allume au greffe au lei
wen ya le grand favori ouais ben tonnes
après il était très désavantagé par
l'horaire de son match il avait voulu
avancer son match de deux heures quand
même mais finalement je sens sans en
connaître les raisons ça pas pu être
possible
donc oui entonne anton est très très
défavorisé et il est moins fort de base
donc c'est un énorme problème pour le
joueur australien
bon après la première partie il s'est
plutôt bien débrouillé n'ya le cap a
très bien joué et niall qui n'est pas
très bien joué son premier tour non plus
hein honnêtement on n'a pas on n'a pas
pas eu un niveau 2 ou fait jusqu'à
maintenant dans ces speech s il ya
peut-être sam sévillans qui avait un peu
impressionnant défense mais en soi il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas eu un niveau de
malades
c'est normal après un camp jeudi niveau
de malades ccc les niveaux des adultes
c'est les niveaux des mv ld nakad et
carl scène des dénés peau des sceaux de
ce qu'on peut retrouver quand on a
vraiment le haut niveau on sent qu a
quand même un gouffre un bon là la
position il ya personne qui se détache
vraiment il n'y a pas de problème réel
ni pour l'un ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre
position assez équilibré d'ailleurs une
fois qu'on aura joué des cinq échanges
et les pions centraux l'aller les pions
seront symétrique les en face des autres
tu pense qu'il va avoir ce niveau m vers
adultes ou c'est trop tard pour pour la
plupart d'entre eux c'est trop tard
baron ce mondial sarine c'est possible
jeffrey dion que c'est possible mais
pour tous les autres noms comme je
disais même entonne spears a enfin vu
son âge etc
alala sa carrière est derrière lui en
face et sera jamais un top mondial un
prêt c'est pas un mal
c'est très difficile d'arriver au top
mondial aux échecs mais ce ne sont pas
des joueurs qui marqueront l'histoire
des échecs ça c'est évident bah oui non
sa carrière derrière lui c'est quelqu'un
qui eux qui menacera jamais d'être
champion du monde
même de loin il menacera même jamais
participé aux candidats quoi fin on n'y
peut rien c'est comme ça c'est la vie
jeffrey xiang pourrait théoriquement un
jour aller aux candidats c'est possible
avec joe pourquoi parce que pour leur
âge ils sont trop en retard sur le
niveau qu'ils devraient avoir
c'est comme ça
c'est comme ça un sam sevian aurait
peut-être pu le faire mais il a décidé
de faire des études et de faire autre
chose de sa vie
et pourquoi pas et hand slimana hend
slimana il est très doué mais il est
très probable
il a commencé les échecs tard donc à
voir il est probable qu'ils deviennent
jamais rien mais
mais c'est pas sûr il a commencé
vraiment tard après les mêmes pas grand
maître encore un il a l'air d'avoir un
certain talent mais à bon à voir mais il
a l'air un peu fou fou aussi bon à voir
j'avais dit paraît quand même mais elle
avait 18 en un an
c'est l'impression l'effet que news que
valence aww qui va peut-être se faire
banques allemandes c4 parce qu'il en va
beaucoup de il écrit beaucoup de la
merde quand même sur le tchat
hansson savoir il est comme il a
commencé tard il peut avoir une courbe
de progression différentes
on verra en 3 qui s'est mystérieusement
à 11 12 ans et le plus près dans cette
nouvelle génération cf6 roux déjà bien
sûr
donc voilà je fus sur ton niveau tu
progresse avec l'âge ingenio on
progresse avec l'âge là c'est
intéressant ce que fait ni alain il a
envoyé un pion mais il veut essayer de
mettre les tours sur la deuxième pour
attaquer le roi c'est comme pour tous
les sports en fait
christopher ue à voir christophe hériaud
à voir
giroud jeunes jouant dans pas longtemps
mais il joue le norway de chasse qui
commence lundi et que je commenterai sur
ma chaîne perso du coup à partir de
lundi à partir de lundi on suivra ce
tournoi ensemble sur ma chaîne perso et
je vous cache pas que j'espère que les
gens qui aiment bien les parties longues
enverrons un peu d seube ce que ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps et c'est pour
vous faire vivre un peu le haut niveau
qui y avait un peu disparu
j'espère avoir le soutien de la commune
dans un seul de ma part pendant le
tournoi
merci tard zolder alors là il ya un très
joli coup d'ordinateur j'ai quasiment
envie de faire un screenshot je me fais
un screenshot je me fais plaisent je
vous laisse le chercher je me fais un
screenshot parce que ça peut faire un
super exercice je me permets un désolé
j'ai envie je me fais un screenshot
je le mettrais en exode sur ce qu'il est
il est bien il a raté sarine alors est
ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui trouve qu'ils
trouvent le gain ici
bon alors hein c'était c'était ici après
tavel et b4 ouais c'était tour d2 tchad
liszt parce qu'on ne peut pas prendre il
ya maths il ya mat du couloir du coup
tours b1 pour aller protéger le cavale
et cavaliers f4 et du coup on a le temps
de d'aller mater le roi de l'autre côté
t'auras plein de s'agit d'un parc en
majesté sera bien joué en tt qui aime
bien châtie bien
je crois que j'aurais jamais de moncef
de grosshof de ta par spike byron twitch
j'ai plus de chances de bien jouer moi
du coup et bien jouer chaque vitre
simple pour pour le tour des deux bien
vu c'était assez joli comme coup avec le
dames 1 bien bien bienvenue à toi j'ai
trouvé je trouvais le mat du couloir
assez original alors là les noirs ont un
pion de plus s'il pouvait l'amener en a
deux ils seraient probablement gagnant
quoique même pas sûr mais le problème
c'est qu'avec les fous de couleurs
opposées le foot blanc va pouvoir venir
en des quatre essais ça rime qui propose
nul et c'est plutôt noir de faire nul
parce que damas est fou des katzav a
attaqué g7
bon il va mettre la dame angers 6 effet
faire le statu quo comme ça ouais c'est
ça attendez c'est moi qui ait bougé la
pièce par inadvertance mais c'est ce
qu'il a joués et sur h 4 h 5
et on peut attendre comme ça dont il va
prendre ch prend 1 tu veux jouer le gain
ouais c'est ce qui va faire les noirs
qui ont peu de temps il peut lui faire
le coup du berger à la bergère
il va envoyer deux pions f5 il va faire
un échec et revenir comme ça il peut
prés move rapidement aller reviens je
comprends pas pourquoi il a pas prêt
move damev 7 en fait ce que quoi qu'il
se passe c'était le coup là il doit
apprendre et il va faire ça pour pas se
faire mater sur la 8e et la dame prend
un f5 et le prochain coup dame g8 et des
qui peut damer fuite à il va y avoir f6
encore si on prend fou prend f6 roy
croit g8 et il n'y a pas de maths
apparemment général on n'y a pas de
maths dans cette rue caf ou de couleur
opposée c'est bizarre en nature
l'impression que qu'on va réussir à
mater et maintenant dame g6 et dames
quatre échecs pour faire un nul pourrait
très bien joué de la part de niall
fallait pas fallait pas rester
il fallait pas rester dans ce délire là
sous pression avec l'euro un peu dans
et dans les cordes il fallait absolument
tout est changé tout cas j'ai pris mon
petit screenshot donc on a une une
cambridge springs et vous avez pu la
voir cette ouverture dans une vidéo que
je vous ai fait y'a pas longtemps sur la
partie karlsson kasparov lorsque magnus
avait 13 ans qui disait que le speech à
c'est un échec d'audience moi et je
confirme qu'au stade où il ya du monde
qui regarde uniquement parce qu'à une
première page c'est tout mais alors il
n'y a qu'à voir le nombre de gens qui
aillent dans le chat tu peux pas du coup
il fallait forcément enfin on mettra un
écran noir il y aurait trois mille
quatre cents personnes aussi quoi c'est
c'est pour ça qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui regardent en anglais
c'est pour ça que des fois vous voyez 10
11 12 13 14 15 mille personnes en
anglais ce que je vous dis souvent c'est
pour ça qu'il faut souvent regardés
l'activité d'un chat plutôt pour pour
comprendre s'il ya vraiment du monde
c'est la presse ouais bon du coup
peut-être le cavalier qui peut venir en
c5 peut être intéressant parce que ça
bloque bien cette position sur pareil
c'est père de fou pour les noirs mais
moi j'aime bien les blancs ce truc là
envoyé spécial c'est bien et c'est
tellement redondance en est là sans
comme format en plus c'est souvent 0
suspense qui a le chat et le streamer
qui tiennent la baraque
bah ouais après enoch le truc là et
c'est sur pareil tu as tout à fait
raison de le noter tant qu'il y avait
que le speech as adulte et que ça
faisait à une dizaine de matches par an
ça allait mais quand tu arrives à 60 70
matches par an avec ce format c'est trop
speech est seigneur tu préfères bon
après le format reste d'après moins
mauvais mais mais oui bien sûr c'est
mieux
après il suffit juste de comparer le
chat avec avec un quart de finale 2 bis
stream invitationnal on était mille cinq
cent premières pages
c'est un personnage apparaît sur la page
principale c'est intéressant après
j'essaye de rendre le truc intéressant
maximum mais on pourrait faire beaucoup
mieux donc là assurant qu'elle et qui va
venir en c5 vous prend ses cinq tours
prend ses 5 va faire dame ces deux tours
c'est un
tenter ça
ok 1 5 point et bien ce qu'ils
fabriquent pour moi la de ce match
signal sarine tu veux jouer contre ce x
8 qui sortent pas en réalité sera chanté
6 le dise quoi c'est réaliste loup blanc
c'est un discours réaliste vous prend
ses cinq tours de france et cinq dames
ces deux tours c'est un ca discours de
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude de commenter
des événements c'est sévère mais juste
way
il faut un peu de sincérité est tout de
même
sinon sinon ce serait mort est donc
position mieux pour les blancs il perd
la casse des six aussi qui peut
s'allumer si le fou et lecavalier s'est
changée ce cas relic si on pouvait le
transférer jusqu'en des 6es du rhin mais
par un chemin un peu long pour y arriver
et il pourrait faire mal il pourrait
faire mal donc les blancs dans les
blancs sont mieux mais anton qui a bien
défendu tout à l'heure une position
comme ça un petit peu resserré mais vu
qu'ils font ça à dix ans pour avoir des
modes qui les as d'escoeuilles à des
trucs qui mis en place pour lutter
contre sa cave non justement d'où il
n'ya rien vraiment qui est mis en place
et il ya notamment un genre de scandale
là qui est en train d'augmenter par
rapport à la prod celle ci d'une
compétition qu'on a commenté le le
week-end dernier avec 1
l'armée dit gate on va dire qu'ils en
train de qui est en train d'augmenter la
avec avec des joueurs qui sont plaints
de tricher aucune preuve
c'est en train de partir dans quelque
chose d'assez moche on va voir on va
voir où ça mène mais mais voilà je sais
pas j'espère que l'arménie sera pas
sanctionné à titre personnel on verra
bien ce qui se passe pour moi il n'y a
aucune preuve
il n'y a aucune preuve qui est une aide
extérieure donc bon je n'aime pas trop
la présomption de culpabilité
on verra bien ce qui se passe je vois
pas comment il pourrait être sanctionné
mais on verra
un truc qui pourrait être logique c'est
de bouger la dame angers 4 et est de
faire passer la tour ans c'est un truc
c'est qu'on peut pas faire dame ces deux
on ne peut pas faire dame sait déjà que
deux tours prend des 4 ouais c'est
possible qu'ils étaient tout à fait
légitimes hongrie pologne de toute façon
même même même si à 1% de doute vu qu'il
ya aucune preuve ils ne peuvent pas être
bannis d'après moi le pour-cent de doute
suffi à ce que leur à ce que leurs
résultats soient comptabilisés après aux
organisateurs de se débrouiller pour
faire en sorte que qui est des mesures
adéquates 1 mais mais mais voilà alors
je pense que l'idée sur dame français 5
c soit fou prend 1,7 soit damage 5
mais ça pourrait ressembler à ça l'idée
est sur roy prend un set d'un match 5
échecs et puis on prend ces cinq qui
tuerait le clouage il a fêté ses 7
il veut tour 17 ans bêtement et attaquer
le pion et il protège aussi le cavalier
dans certaines variantes non mais le
problème comme je disais c'est que si on
se met à virer l'arménie pour leurs
performances
est ce qu'on garde hikaru par exemple
géré par là après on peut avoir
l'argument pour tout le monde
ces performances sont bien meilleures en
ligne quand réel du coup il n'y a aucune
preuve de rien mais on va virer tout le
monde dans ces cas là sans aucune preuve
de rien ça va être la vendetta ça va
être la vendetta du coup donc ya pas
c'est la chasse aux sorcières après un
si on rentre là d'angelin déjà parlé
hier mais c'est la chasse aux sorcières
on s'en sort plus après si on commence à
virer accuser les gens sur suspicion
c'est pour moi y aille
il y aura même plus moyen de participer
aux compétitions en ligne parce que du
coup il suffit qu'il fasse un bon
résultat tu seras viré d'office donc
donc pour moi en aucun cas les joueurs
arménien devrait avoir de problème l'on
verra un donc là le truc c'est que le
roi noir va être faible enfin on peut
vouloir faire des cavaliers j'ai quatre
cavaliers f6 soucaille prend h6 les
pièces noires sont un peu immobilisé
quoi le pion s'est bloquée qu'en dire le
fou ou 8 on peut pas vraiment le faire
jouer le seul contre jeu ils résistent
sur le pion des quatre genres la foux
pranger scission pranger 6e regarder le
cavalier psy fait genre h quatre dames
quatre cavaliers j'ai deux cavaliers f4
s'il a le temps 1 la seule chance c'est
vraiment de réussir à immobiliser les
pièces blanches sur des 4 mais regardez
ce que 8,1 il tahita étape dans du dur
si lecavalier ont réussi à le mettre sur
des six est quasi fini qui s'est plaint
de triche de la part des arméniens ils
sont accusés publiquement par un certain
wes les sauts c'est quand même ce qui
est quand même étrange reims et quand
même les états unis un pays démocratique
étonnant de la part d'un joueur
américain comme ça de d'accuser sans
aucune preuve
ouais du coup tout reprend b4 c'est
marrant parce que sarine était très bien
mais là il se retrouve complètement
foutu et le fou qui va jaillir terrible
un pur a fourni à la presse pas fini
encore mais quand la tour va arriver
date tous réfutent peut-être dame
pranger 5 pour preuve de away ça ça fait
mal ça ça ça fait très mal ton problème
devait être joué évidemment alors celle
là où celle là j'en sais rien pas un
grand match de la part de sarine il ya
foule quatre échecs aussi qui était
possible lors il n'a pas pris mais la
river food et 3 de façon très fin
c'était pas un grand coup ça servait à
air et la tourache de tours h 1 ça va
faire maths petit macho niall sarine
pour le moment ça joue de manière assez
faible côté indien et le joueur
australien qui pour le moins l'air dans
son match après ce qui va résister au
sommeil
on avait vu un peu ralentir et baissé le
pied un an son premier tour
compliqué
compliqué mais ni à louer qui a pas
réussi il a eu deux bonnes positions
avec les blancs une position de pression
des positions de travail et les deux
fois il s'est fait retourner étonnant
alors là le truc c'est que sur cavaliers
prend si on prend dame prend ya
peut-être ces cinq dames bouger c4 qui a
un truc classique
ok donc il a fait quoi refait de voir la
tactique il a fait preuve cette tempête
qui prend 1,5 et si on joue un coup
comme cavalier si c'était quoi l'idée
prise elle est prise à vii et 5 1 avec
damas trois échecs et dame prend à 8
d'accor donc vu que ça a joué vite ça
devait exister ce truc là on en fait
voir le bilan des courses les blancs ou
un pion plus mais ya de l'activité pour
les noirs ouais en fait à la tour
ouverte sur la colonne f&a un fou braqué
là dessus est à l'autre ou braquer quand
même sur le pion qui peut tomber
dangereux ces variantes là on va voir
comment ni à le continue
chants des gens très nerveux dans le
chatt aujourd'hui je sens un chat
nerveux ici tour f5 peut être un coup
pour attaquer le pion
dia rivet mater pas de tampon 1 pour le
moment malheureusement ça va passer par
là
peut-être tour f st cloud prend des 5
pas quand il veut défendre l'option en
fait plus je réfléchis plus je comprends
pas jamie noon qui moi je sens bien le
petit ce milliard d' affront avoir un on
va voir s'il peut boire son adversaire
ou s'il va se faire fumer par sarine
matour f53 5 semble être un coup pour
attaquer le pion je vois pas comment tu
le défends parce qu'évidemment on a
passé quatre à cause de la prise en
passant un il fait d'un f 6 d'accord je
toujours pas compris ceux passés sur
tours f5 pour vous dire en réalité
torres 5 c'était aussi le coup numéro de
l'ordi sarek le coup paraît que c'est
vraiment très logique
il doit voir jouer dame f5
je sens pas un niveau de jeu de ouf ce
soir après les deux joueurs jouent
beaucoup mieux que moi c'est pas ce pas
ce que je veux dire mais mais j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on est cons qu'ils
soient super fort alors prise prise
prise alors qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
sur dame france et 3 sûrement tourbe et
attaquer le fou puis four b2 pour contre
attaquer sur g7
ça doit être l'idée
sur neuf qui est parti qui revient
il prend un tour bien ça va être joué
c'est sûr autour des 8 il va y avoir
foule b2 mais la dame qui va repartir
peut-être pardon tu attends c4 pour
revenir en d5
les nommés square des joueurs français
dans ce tournoi n'ont peut-être l'année
prochaine on aura marre quand marc-andré
amaro risi j'espère en tout cas qu'on
retrouvera bientôt dans ces speech est
junior ça ne mettra un petit peu d'un
petit peu de piment
allez peut-être un dame c4 pour dames
prendrait 5 ce qui paraît plus logique
hein
ils sont pas ensemble parce qu'ils sont
encore un peu jeunes marquant je crois
qu'ils en moins de 14
donc il est encore un peu jeune mais
peut-être d'ici un ou deux ans il pourra
participer à ce tournoi ce sera cool
hein le matériel est encore plus jeunes
on va les laisser grandir on verra ce
qui donne un c'est toujours difficile
d'anticiper la carrière qu'auront des
jeunes joueurs il peut arriver tellement
de choses que ce soit des choses
positives ou négatives 1.5 et prend 1,5
dame prend des saints qui va menacer
m'attend j'ai deux donc il faudra
reprendre prendrai quand il y aura qu
ali prend dé cette fourchette
il pourra échanger une tour et dirigé la
partie vers une nulle
le gagnant affrontera qui je crois qu'il
affrontera le vainqueur du match qu'on
aura demain qui sera entre sévillan et
je sais plus qui
oui à faire dame prend dé 5,1 ce cammas
élémentaire pas vraiment d'autres coups
sûrs qu'à aider cette dame prend g de
maths et maintenant qu'il est prend 17
il y avait tout reprend b12 faire fou
aussi ce qui a aidé sept fous 17 tours
et sûrement tourbe et de uturoa 8 c'est
assez juste et galles qui affrontera
l'arménie vers vous croyez il a le
gagnant affronte martirossian du coup ne
serait se tromper
d'un autre côté ça me fait bien et aussi
d'origine arménienne du coup et si mes
souvenirs sont bons
peut-être juste tours fc est en histoire
de
bien arrêter le truc montant des mythes
aussi ça c'est nul de chez nul égalité
matérielle et y'a pas moyen de 2
réellement pressé va essayer quand même
de jeu peut-être un peu le pion c'est
bon après il va l'être précis les
joueurs ils ont raison ça devrait pas
aller bien loin
le pion s'est passé oui mais bon il peut
il va être rapidement arrêté un peut
même devenir un point faible
wayne yal ce même à l'otan et où il joue
trop lentement il aurait pu beaucoup
plus vite ce début de finale il faut
vraiment très lentement question
pourrait lui faire une vidéo sur les
nationalités aux échecs dans quelques
soirs lips il enfin je sais pas je
comprends pas trop le le sens que pourra
voir la vidéo
mais pour pour les études ça a déjà été
fait d'où le vrai savait pas très bien
marché trop compliqué bon ça fait nul
non parce qu'il n'y a là un excellent
joueur de bullet mes joues pas vite pour
le moment mais si tu auras du bit sur ma
chaîne ce soir écoute j'espère après je
suis vraiment fatigué du coup on verra
2800 ça va être dur j'ai pas assez de
vacances pour ça quand maître gims et
j'étais pas loin mais le problème c'est
que ton chesnais trop de trop d'heures
de stream déjà le stream fait fait
perdre 30 40 points et l'air ajoutant la
fatigue peut-être 60 60 80 quoi et c'est
comme ça daniel qui s'est levé qui est
parti en tonnes qui font une bonne
décision contre la nuit c'est de manger
parfois comme un excellent joueur de
bullet soul est mal autant au bit soit
et c'est vrai souvent quand tu sais que
tu peux jouer vite et en garde un peu
plus ou un peu moins sous le coup de
quoi
là normalement larbitre devrait
évidemment vu que c'est très facile de
de tricher même en étant face de la
caméra
ben on laisse les joueurs se lever mais
ça prouve bien que il n'ya rien à faire
un comment les joueurs changent si
souvent de nationalité
en fait tu changes de fédérations pas de
nationalité et psion est parfois il ya
des gens qui leur donne des passeports
parce qu'on peut on peut changer de
nationalité mais ils se font acheter
entre guillemets enfin les américains
ils achètent les joueurs en fait
tam ces deux il repart ce terrible
peut-être qu'il est malade après aniane
arrivés à ben je pense que tu vas tu vas
prendre un petit à petit ban de dix
minutes un pas de politique ici va pas
commencer à à lancer des débats
ça n'arrête pas un band f mais ça mérite
un petit ban temporaire quand même
bon y'a rien d'intrigants réalité sinon
il ya juste des fédérations qui de temps
en temps achète des joueurs c'est tout
en fait est absolument un intéressant
c'est bien de file australien parce que
ses parents sont allés vivre en
australie ni à elsa il est un diamant ce
qu'il est né en inde
moi je suis français puisque je suis né
en france enfin je sais pas il 2h52 du
mat walsh et entonne donc qui jouent à
peu près la même structure que dans la
première niall ménaka il est américano
japonais mais du coup je vous pour les
états unis mais je crois qu'il a vécu
toute sa vie aux états unis gros les
gens sont nés dans un pays ils ont la
nationalité quoi c'est comme dans la vie
de tout le monde
fil rouge a pour le moment il est
iranien oui après ce qu'un jour il aura
un passeport français ou pas ça c'est
une autre question mais jusqu'à preuve
du contraire il est iranien après
changer de passeport ça existe de
partout hein
island c'est dans l'esprit de
l'hémisphère nord mais ils ont caché
joueur anthony la 19 ans et niall 16
je vais juste avant de se coucher c'est
idéal non normalement t'es plus en forme
le matin ou en début de journée
mon visa gamer
m'étonnerais pas ce que je voulais dire
je les ai pas parlé des lois spécifiques
à tous les pays mais en gros la
nationalité des joueurs elle vient de
l'endroit où ils sont nés ou de leurs
parents mais j'ai rien de spécial et
joueur d'échecs tu te laves pas joueur
d'échecs et à ce jeu là tout joueur
d'échecs je vais être faron s'est passé
jusque quand même pas la question en
fait c'est pas tu te lèves feinter
français je vous pour la france point
barre tu es américain du jeu pour les
états unis étaient russie joue pour la
russie ça va pas beaucoup plus loin que
ça mises à part quelques cas spéciaux
comme dans absolument tous le monde qui
nous entoure dans 99,9 pour cent des cas
c'est ça
d'un point de vue général c'est ça y'a
pas de yahia paille a pas d'énorme
spécificité pour les échecs comme jude
est la seule petite spécificité des
échecs c'est que tu peux avoir joué pour
un pays et te faire payer par un autre
pays pour changer de nationalité jouer
pour un autre pays par la suite
c'est un peu là la seule spécificité des
échecs c'est sincère c'est comme ça
vanne bape et demain tu as brésil qui
veut le faire jouer en équipe nationale
il le paye lui file un passeport
brésilien et joue pour le brésil c'est
la seule spécificité des échecs par
rapport au foot par exemple ce que vous
ne serez pas possible tu tues fin on
peut pas acheter des équipes nationales
aux échecs tu peux tu peux faire les
olympiades pour la france et ce d'après
pour les états unis mais ça c'est pour
les nationalités pour les clubs le
spécifie spécificités des échecs c'est
qu'on peut joué pour plusieurs clubs
voilà c'est comme le qatar ou handball
exactement
suiveur et les 0,6 c'est exactement ça
ouais je mette un ban en bande des
familles au gamer spam beaucoup trop
mais c'est la seule spécificité aux
échecs mais après l'échangé nationalité
ça va coûter une blinde que le joueur
achète axatois exactement il ya des pays
qui sont prêts à payer très cher pour
que le pour que des joueurs changent de
nationalité mais après ça leur rapporte
absolument rien c'est juste comme ça
c'est juste comme ça mondial qui se fait
quand même domine en ce début de match
et il est mal autant à chaque fois il
n'obtient jamais davantage un f4 double
attaque oui mais alors damev si soudain
f5 et clouage sur le roi
il a pris ses 7 il va y avoir une
reprise de la tour probablement et tour
c1
wen yal qui a besoin de trouver ses
marques il m'impressionne pas du tout
mais après là il ya peut-être un petit
des quatre peut être pénible
il se débarrasse du pion isolé et il
tape de partout lightapp sur des points
faibles d'un même si soudain mf5 je
mettrais plutôt f6 perso mais f5 elle
peut avoir ses rebonds que de façon si
prend des quatre peut prendre f4 génial
qui jouent lentement il a pas l'air
d'être dans le match du tout niall là
ils pensent avoir g4 j'imagine donc et
prend des 4 alors j'ai dit une bêtise il
peut par contre en f4 parce que ses
protégés désolé mais il peut prendre en
b3 donc faire dame détroit et prendre en
vrai prendre mais trop prendre des
quatre s'y prend des quatre l'autre dame
eux trois ils échangent et fou prend b3
assez nul donc il prend b3
donc finale de foot couleurs opposées
une nouvelle fois mais que trois
secondes pour venir al sarine il se met
beaucoup trop mal autant après la tête
par l'uni 30 à aller aux toilettes ou
jeunes saison là le fou qui va venir en
dessin qui va attaquer ici la finale
doit être nul mais elle peut être
pénible à jouer celle là l'est peut-être
d'amsterdam prend un f4 d'ailleurs là
mesdames sein il avait damé fin encore
bon il tient il tient il tient et il
tient en gros il tient tous ses points
faibles avec sa dame elle est bien
placée
ça va me revient au 4 mai le truc c'est
que tout est défendu
à pouvoir le truc s'il faut qu'ils
créent des menaces avec les noirs pour
le faire tomber
mais c'est la même histoire que tout à
l'heure même si f6 g5 qui pousse le pion
ça va mener à rien ces deux c'est bien
il fait ça fait fuiter attention de pas
se faire mater en un après quand il fait
g5 comprend pions prend n'y a pas
d'échec ans et 7 c'est plutôt cool pour
lui j'ai ici s'il veut voilà c'est pour
ça qui fait pousser 5c pour couvrir et
va devoir faire f5 pour couvrir damage
cathy laura ouais bon il y avait d'alger
de maths mais de façon saddam elle peut
venir là au cas de besoin dan d2 il veut
pousser à b4 et maintenant il va faire
b4 b3 b2b 1 c'est très bien joué là ce
qu'il vient de faire
anton et maintenant b3 b2b 1 avec peu de
temps la pendule c'est tellement dur de
défendre arelate échange des dames et
cette finale là elle doit se gagner sans
trop de problèmes
mial qui joue vraiment très malin ce
match il est loin de son meilleur niveau
elle était très difficile à défendre
avec si peu de temps pour pour le joueur
indien et ça finit par craquer et ça
finit par craquer
sylvain millet pas dedans wayne on en
irak qui est pas dedans honnêtement il
et il est loin de son meilleur niveau
donc là je vais petit ragots zine donc
là l'idée des noirs c'est de réussir à
jouer cinq pour libérer le foie nous n'a
bloqué ans et 8 et essayer de l'amener
vers f5 coup j'ai 4 way saillenard plus
fatigué alors après on connaître on ne
connaît pas les habitudes de vie des 2 1
peut-être que sarine se couche tôt il
boit de manière un peu bizarre en tout
cas j'ai pas comment il boit il ferme
les yeux avant de boire esquissé bois
car c'est bien affûté pas tenir après il
peut y avoir quatre ans est exact
parce qu'ils voient l'eau du gange celle
du gange
bon là la question sur la même un est ce
que les noirs se font enfermer ou est ce
qu'ils peuvent libérer toujours pareil
on essaie de pousser s'il est noir
réussissent à libérer ça fait mal mais
bon la case 5 est bien contrôlée indien
vaut mieux que deux tu l'auras comme on
dirait non mais anton qui voient de
manière plus normal on voit boire les
bois de manière complètement normal sari
nice je sais pas ce qu'il fait
c'est un peu étonnant
s'il y en a fallu apprendre à boire mais
il se remet à réfléchir des plombs bien
il est pas dans n'y aie il n'est
vraiment pas dans le match
salut super saut à skis les jeunes
talents qui ont fait le show beaucoup de
pons a joué assez malin globalement côté
indien ouais on tonnes qui fait le taff
sens et que ce n'était pas tombé très
bêtement dans la première il pourrait y
avoir 4 1 ouais là ils sont enfoncés
sarine
alors là c'est abécédaire de ce qu'il
faut pas faire avec les noirs maintenant
il est ici sévissant aux 5 ce qui semble
être possible c'est pas encore fait mais
ce qui semble être possible sont fous
ces huit il joue plus jamais il n'a pas
de case donc la torah 8 jouera pas et
c'est fini nous au coeur le fallu mettre
quelque chose sur ton fond vert bah
écoute merci du conseil du doubs doit
être un streamer pro un pour pour donner
des conseils comme ça ça fait plaisir ça
avoir une très grosse chaîne
il ya un gars qu'à la fin du tournoi
ouailles à 25000 dollars de prix je
crois en tout
bon il veut essayer de faire f 6 e 5 en
force libérée le fou avec des cahiers
des six cavaliers à vii peut-être son
fouet fin est pas terrible mais hey tu
veux dire alors je suis pas de calais de
kahel foutu par me lasser ses 8 9 8 mai
à steph nous parle d'un des deux fous
voilà à gauche jallet ya des petits
chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et le de rachat
c'est vrai que c'est pas il n'ya pas le
truc sur toutes les cases doigts et des
échiquiers se sont en réelles ou sur
certains sites où il ya le nom de la
case à l'intérieur là il faut la placer
sur l'échiquier les numéros mais c'est
pas sûr chaque case tout cas way le fou
c'est 8 est bloqué je suis d'accord avec
toi le foie fuite et lui peut revivre le
foie fuite il peut revivre
paresse qui va essayer de faire f 6 5 il
doit être en train de calculer mais
comment ce cas et des six heures sur
pions prend qui on prend cavaliers prend
il veut revenir et avoir foi f5 après ok
il aurait sacrifié un pion mais au moins
ils réactivent ces pièces
avec les noirs je rends pls on n'aime
pas jouer sur trois lignes
4 tu vas sûrement devoir partir pour f 6
e 5 1 quand même un jour ou l'autre
tu peux pas garder ces pièces sont
fermés et bon une nouvelle fois le même
problème est en train de se dessiner à
nouveau pour une île sarine c'est le
problème de la pendule françois qui le
vrai problème c'est la torah vite way
après il est lié aux fous ces huit donc
c'est pour ça que les met dans le même
sac après savais que je pouvais faire
fou bouge tout revient à et repartir ans
et 8 ça irait mais oui niall qui jouait
juste trop lentement dans ce premier
segment il a encore une minute 40 de
retard c'est beaucoup trop
alors il s'en prend aux pions des 4 et
surtout ces trois il veut sûrement
prendre deux fois
je pense qu'il va prendre le pion un thé
peut-être un problème est peut-être un
tour d un tour prend des huit qui mêla
d'amendé 5
c'est plutôt bien ce qui réussit à faire
niall ici
il s'est un peu active et maintenant le
problème c'est que si on réussit à lui
interdire 5
il va il a tout ramené il peut pas aller
plus loin en fait dans son activité tant
qu'ils jouent pas eu ça en fait ils à
ces trois pièces qui joue si avec ce 5 5
pièces contre trois ont réussi à
interdire 5 les noirs ne peuvent plus
amélioré leur position c'est ça le
problème à l'est il attaque un peu enfin
il regarde un peu là ils regardent un
peu là à mon avis veut 5 et fouet 5
je pense qu'il faut qu'ils envoient aux
cinq ici à mes tours h4 mais il aura
d'un f 5 au pire bouffe wef sa dame f5
sûrement je serais partisan d'un coup
comme 5
il faut de toute façon se libérer alors
la fois f5 ya peut-être des échecs
intermédiaire avoir dame c4 il veut
fouet aux 6es la dame qui va repartir
vers 2 j'imagine et surtout f5 leur tour
y aura tourache 4 passes qui aura plus
le clouage mais il y aura encore un
clouage ici c'est compliqué
infosys et maintenant
peut aussi faire dame f1 ou dame c1 ou
dame quelque part avec l'idée que sur
ios 5 du coup il y aura tour h4 et qui
se prendra pas le clouage cependant
menacerait le coup que je regarderai
ce que j'aurais joué aussi ça consolide
de 5 sur fond f5 au pire on pourra
surfer dame c4 est allé en f1 dans un
deuxième temps alors alors d'y proposer
un truc très fort ces cavaliers des
quatre équidés dame prend tout reprendre
mais ça c'est très difficile à voir
c'est pas genre de coups qu'on joue donc
comme je disais le problème c'est qu'on
peut pas prendre des sissi prend 1,4 sur
van damme c4 et d'un mets fins mais là
il se fait mal autant entonne arrive à
prendre là nul non ça aurait été un peu
triste un de faire nul ouais tour trois
bons il veut plus on prend cavaliers
prend poussé 5-fu des quatre ça va
échanger fou prend des quatre il va
reprendre de la tour puis on prend
cavaliers prendre dame prend prise voilà
toujours un pion de plus avec les blancs
allez faut reprendre de la tour ici
c'est tellement logique prend du
cavalier ou alors barque
c'est logique aussi f3 puis on prend il
va prendre prendre prendre prendre et
prendre alors il a quoi il un pion de
plus m et surtout la halle pioncer si ce
qui est bien placé et sert que c'est le
jour où il prend ses sept en fait il est
quasiment dames et g3 hkd j'imagine ah
non ça va être gagnant un petit tour des
cinq ici un petit tour f5 tourcoing fc 3
ou 4 ça doit gagner la finale d'options
doit gagner il est pas rentrer là il
gagne c'est sûr tour f 5 tours fc est 3e
5 c'est un abandon immédiat puisque le
roi est trop et trop trop entrer dans le
camp noir sur recettes y a juste pu
comprendre wife 5,3 à roye pranger 5e ça
fait plus de pour anton écoutez là je
suis quand même surpris
l'impression que ça rime pour pouvoir
réellement y avoir cinq ares 1
ouais mais là c'est vraiment étonnant
sarine qui est je trouve quand même loin
de son meilleur niveau
on va voir s'il réussit à remonter mais
là il est il est vraiment pour moi très
loin de son meilleur niveau alors là il
ya fou prend et c5 direct ah oui 90 ans
cette vente la lada mais on 17
non mais il faut qu'il apprenne à voir
quand même nom là par contre apprendre à
boire et quand même la mévente avec la
dame on sait qui est en train de jouer
il aurait eu cinq ici pas non là
vraiment
de rester deux ou trois parties dans la
cadence il s'est pris le bouchon je sais
pas ce qu'il fait et il s'est hissé pas
boire un très clairement
très clairement arrête de réfléchir a eu
4 ou c4 position est quasiment égal
peut espérer tu as une petite pression
après pions prend qu'il va les prendre
il peut avoir un trio de pièces sur le
roi autour des 8 j'ai bien aimé
bon
ça va changer
quand il s'en fou prend h théâtre d'un
match 5-4 alors effet g6 support juste
j'imagine ou rachis 6 ou g6 dépend de la
position concrète un moment sur puis on
prend des quatre découvertes la dame
prend et son fou il va le mettre en 8 je
pense pour le moment
compliqué pour pour sarine je sens la
caméra je sens dans son jeu qui n'est
pas acquis n'est pas dans son assiette
du coup je me pose une question par
rapport à ces speech est ce qu'il
faudrait pas les jouer sur trois ou
quatre jours est ce que ce serait pas
mieux pour éviter comme ça peut-être
qu'un joueur plus fort ne se fasse
éliminer on serait peut-être plus sur sa
toile son body language à son langage
corporel ça se voit dans ses coups il
n'est pas dedans 9,4 bon coup ouais ça
peut être un bon coup après ces
responsables ça peut être compromettant
mais oui vraiment peut-être faire un
format où on joue quatre heures le mardi
4 heures le jeudi 4 heures le vendredi
et quatre heures le samedi soir est
quand même assez sûr de pas avoir un
problème d'un joueur en méforme sur un
jour pourrait être une solution
il prend des 4
attention même si tu vas prendre b4
pendant les 4 prendre des quatre mais il
pourra pas prendre des captures à tour
ces quatre les moins bien avec les
blancs la raison est simple le pion bk
très faible le cavalier arrivée sur la
bonne case en d4 et le fou maintenant et
le bon foire que le fout des blancs et
mauves est fou elle a un jeu simple coup
comme fou b5 fait mal ils soulignent
toutes les preuves tous les problèmes
des blancs le foot est roi mal placé le
carré lisse et 4 mal placé le pion
beckham sous pression alors sur tours à
3 j'avais demandé en fait il se passe
quoi il veut qu'à valider cinq mais il y
aura tout reprend des cinq tours prend
des 3a il aura tour s'est vite échec non
non non ça va cahier des cinq tient
encore mais il avait peut-être pas vu en
amont puisque la sci là il a refait un
petit coup de pause
ouais non non il est pas dans on a
l'impression qu'il voit autre chose sur
son écran ou vraiment ça se voit sur son
langage corporel il ya quelque chose qui
va pas criaient qui les dessins qui le
voient pas une nouvelle fois il ya un
problème je ne sais pas lequel mais il
ya un problème
il ya un souci c'est pas possible la
france d3 et surtout reprend détroit et
cavaliers deux tours prend des trois
alors a peut-être qui a aidé 5 à la fin
mais il voit rien en fait c'est c'est
clair et net en fait ils jouent du coup
par coup
petite emma une série en même temps
wayne ont écouté je peux pas vous dire
ce qui va pas pour lui mais il ya
quelque chose il ya quelque chose de pas
normal
alors il a fait des paris sur roland
garros je sais pas ce qu'il a fait mais
mais il a pas l'air d'être impliqué dans
le match
bien qu'il serait sinon j'irai pas un
stress je dirais qu'il a l'air préoccupé
par autre chose là en gros la question
c'est ça ce qui a eu sa prise je
voudrais prendre comme ça il ya
peut-être qui est des cinq qui coupe la
connexion des tours après ce que dame
j'ai cinq marches pour contre attaquer
là c'est une autre question
c'est ce qu'on entend est en train de
calculer un alors il a décidé de prendre
comme ça et prendre b4 auquel a pris
cette solution elle n'a pas voulu
prendre la qualité il a dû penser que
c'est trop dangereux
il préférait jouer un coup de dames
l'important des 6 et après faire b 5 qui
sera protégé chez pas s'ils allaient
gagner en tout cas et en dessin qui est
quand même fort il empêche bien b4
ra8 il veut tenter un truc de type tour
en échec 3 h de damages six matches
très clairement je viens tu vas faire un
coup comme dame c'est adam c3i la pâques
avaient lieu de donc il va faire d'âme
des uns ou d'amd un sûrement ça te
permet de réviser des dames h5 parfois
en tout cas il est dans le mal le joueur
le joueur indien gk traces et pas idiot
c'est surtout un roi h2 dans l'âge 6
dames h3 pour moi j'ai trois il n'y a
pas d'âme f4 façon il ya le cavalier qui
protège il fait d'un match 600 premiers
e-menaces toi un matt est ici l'ordi
donne un coup de marloux ces dames à 3
qui est largement visible à ce niveau là
avec l'idée surtout reprend d'avoir tour
s'est vite maths c'est bien joué
allez enfin il commence à viser la zone
là
allez c'est bien ça peut leur mettre en
confiance
damas six tonnes qui continuent à
presser
et la tension de passeront d'un cavalier
de damages 6 1 qui pourrait faire un
math d'anastasia lecavalier contrôlant
les cases de sortie du roi est sûre car
hélios est on imagine droit h suite sur
dame set j'ai peur de camaïeu 2 c'est
pas mal juste mais c'est ma direct
cavale yeux de roy h2 damas six dans
l'âge si ce qu'avait lieu de roy f1
cavaliers f
non mais là il va y avoir un mac c'est
sûr qu'à relief quatre rois g1 damas je
trouve pas le mat cavaliers d'euros et
feng est varois adam f un échec
roy f1 tout rachat un tour un math il
est là le mat cavaliers f4 non il a raté
car il ya quatre d'arrêt fin ça faisait
mat
mesdames f1 rouages de ce ça fait pas
mal c'est terrible de rater ma tante 3
quand même je vais vous le montrez après
si tu arrive de rater un matin 3 quand
même c'était dame f1 et toi ok bon
qu'adam tam tam et cava lieu de heroes
menace d'un match 4 maths et roy a fuité
il ya rien d'alger inde à machin d'un
match de tours à 3 mais il faut qu'ils
aient matin au bout j'ai trois cavaliers
f4 way ou cavaliers g1 et dames proche
d'eux et c'est fini mais je vous
montrais le match qu'il a raté puisqu'il
était jolie attendait il faut que
j'aille voir là dedans
archives sarine
il ya il arriva rate un joli match je
pense après sa demande vérification mais
oui cavalli africa 3g un bon sur roy a
eu un il y avait un peu de maths et
suroît géant dames f1 3h deux dames
âgées de maths donc roi prend et tours 1
il a quand même raté ma tondeuse puisque
on peut dire car élèves quatre dames f1
c'est vrai ma tante 3 il a raté le matin
3 mais ça a suffi à smirnov pour
l'emporter mais quand je vous dis que le
niveau de jeu est pas fou
l'essai camaïeu de avec les découvertes
alors qu'ils pouvaient juste échangé les
dames et essayer de faire nul c'était
pas jojo paris gnagnagna il ya un
problème il me connaît cette sensation
là quand t'es pas en forme que tu te
sens pas bien tu vois tu fatigues un peu
comme ça et c'est ce qui est en train de
lui arriver un ctt pas en confiance tu
montrent des signes d'agacement de
fatigue
ouais j'ai pas compris d'un mais ça se
voyait qu'il y aurait un problème tu te
mets pas sur une découverte comme ça si
tu la vois tes après voilà je jette pas
la princesse est pas la carte du toit
personnes ans il fait ce qu'il peut mais
je veux dire par là que je je je connais
sentiment qu'il a avec les que cagna
lancement ses sentiments quant à
l'impression de d'avoir les yeux qui
voient les cheats iemed pas pouvoir
calculer voix ilfc la fatigue
ouais c'est la fatigue ça arrive très
mauvaise forme ça arrive de temps en
temps
et c'est en tonnes qui s'envolerait
c'est un top player ouais mais on a tous
le droit d'être en méforme et de et
d'être fatigué ça arrive à tout le monde
prayssas qui est parti en mini moto
allait peut-être deux trois minutes tout
à l'heure peut-être qu'il est malade un
web et 4 c'est un très mauvais coup
aussi à françois je suis d'accord avec
toi ali ils ont ils enchaînent les
mauvais coups quoi il a un peu enchaîné
les mauvais coups
c'est comme ça
bon ça va être la dernière partie dans
la cadence je vérifier qu'on ait le bon
chrono tout cas la saa échange de
partout ça peut faire une huile rapide
du valais jeter un oeil aux chronos
c'est quand même important
je vais regarder le chrono officiel pour
être bien sûr pour être bien sûr je
trouve le live officiel de chess comme
ce qui n'est pas gagné pour la finale ça
ce n'est pas grand chose à dire il ya
tout qui s'est échangé ouais c'est en
tonnes qui est censé être désavantagé
ouais mais après cinq minutes 30
et moi j'ai quoi g4me toi donc il reste
une minute de plus
après il est peut-être pas du tout
motivé pour ce tournoi il peut avoir
plein de raisons 1
mais même cette finale qui était
complètement insipide tu as l'impression
qu'il va se retrouver moins bien c'est
le compte à rebours est mais le truc ce
compte à rebours ichigo c'est moi qui le
met et du coup je n'ai pas le compte à
rebours officiel
anthony l'air serein ben tu sens après
un canton adversaire joue mal il va
monter leur en f4 il va pousser g5
tuchan canton adversaire est un peu un
peu dans le dur
forcément ça te
si tu étais un peu fatiguée si l'entente
est un peu fatigué de son côté ou quoi
au contraire lui va être plus serein
maintenant c'est c'est des vases
communicants
c'est des vases communicants je pense
qu'il va échanger les tours voilà les
bienvenus le sang les tours comme ça
c'est bien nul de chez nul
ag il donne un ouais mais en fait tu
rentres pas il donne rien du tout
on sort ww spada ça c'est nul
après peu essayé de temporiser pour
aller jusqu'à la fin du chrono time qui
propose nulle part la place d'anthony je
garderai la proposition nul j'attendrai
fait cuire à la fin du 5 + 1 sarah n
relancer une partie propose nul mhadjou
et stratégiquement 7 nuls deux ans
tonnes il n'a pas besoin de jouer une
partie de plus très mal joué
stratégiquement stratégie de match
voulais qu'ils attendent qui laisse
filer le chrono c'est vrai il utilise
pas les règles à son avantage
n'ayez pas peur c'est tout ils m'ont
après ça rien de jouer 10 minutes de
plus de matchs il ya déjà le match est
déjà long il doit jouer la stratégie de
matches passe pas une question de
fair-play c'est les rakes et les règles
peut-être qu'il en confiance ouais c'est
possible aussi merci à rooney badgers
non c'était pas une question de
fair-play c'est une décision qu'il a
prise elle peut prendre à deux sur
risque est vrai nom est dwayne
permettent un point de plus j'aurais pas
j'aurais déjà et en gestion un perso
j'aurais déjà commencé à gérer le match
côté côté smirnov
ouais donc là ça et le chrono est
terminée on va l'enlever
combien de temps bullet il ya 38 de
bullet quick raid
mais avant d'arriver aux bulles est on
passera par la case 3 + 1 pendant une
heure après après ça avec unia l'a
tellement la tête sous l'eau il joue
tellement mal ce soir une nouvelle fois
ils jouent mal par rapport à son niveau
un attention je vous qui joue très bien
quand même
et par rapport à haut niveau qui peut
afficher il joue quand même assez mal
c'est vrai qui se dit peut-être qu'il va
récupérer pendant la pause donc f3
l'idée c'est de se libérer droits pour
pouvoir aller faire un rock à la main
sans fermer pas la dame toi
ouais alors toi ça enfermer la dame mais
ça lui laisser d'un point qui est un
coût qui paraissait assez bon pour les
noirs ça gagner une course avait été le
roi en échec
je pense c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas
fait tours 1
du coup rock donc ya pas tout reprendre
et 4 à cause de cas et des trois échecs
si vous posez la question c'est la
petite fourchette mais là de signal qui
a une position intéressante non il veut
ag as.g d'un match 7 faire jouer sa tour
h1 serait pas mal qu'il paye sa décision
en tonnes pourrait payer cash sa
mauvaise décision
ça a tout de suite été spots et un
parole commentateurs français gestion
match un peu questionnable et ça
pourrait lui coûter cher
parce que là les blancs semblent avoir
une bonne position le roi noir est
vraiment faible
je pense qu'il va repartir en guerre
prêt peut aussi allant à 4 mais c'est un
peu acrobatique
il peut aller en g4 medica je crois
qu'il ya toujours un dame un pardon
était obligé d'échanger les dames c'est
pas pas évident à gérer pour les noirs
cette interaction jugerait juste retour
des 1 puis on prend roi f2 et après être
repassé les tours comme ça c'est
probablement la décision que je l'aurais
prise au feeling après avec le calcul
parfois on change d'avis tout cas il n'y
ait qui réfléchit
tout reprend des cinq ça m'aurait fait
peur par principe parce que le roi est
au centre
c'est par principe j'aurais eu peur la
larve lazaoui non mais je suis d'accord
mais il ya quelque chose qui va pas est
ce que c'est sa mauvaise forme qui fait
qu'il a l'air blasé
est ce que il a un problème quelconque
est-ce qu'il est malade et ce qu'il n'a
pas envie de jouer il ya quelque chose
dans tous les cas et ça se traduit sur
l'échiquier est là en tonnes et en plus
je rappelle qu'en tonnes est tombé dans
une position bon il était mieux ils
n'étaient pas gagnant une position
facile à la première serre que 6 2
devrait être le score minimum 6 en taux
n'avait pas fait vraiment quelque chose
de n'importe quoi et ça pourrait même
être cette adresse ici 6 ennemis et rémy
à
le score peut-être des crampes d'estomac
rue où il ya peut-être des ulcères comme
je l'avais rhin fois c'est terrible
c'est terrible il a peut-être quelque
chose fait tour à 4 qui est le coup le
plus ambitieux mais le plus dangereux
aussi parce que la tour peut se
retrouver très bizarre ici le pion se
fait attaquer n'imagine roi f2 et
willard et goûter chacun de ses coups ça
sent que ça va pas c'est terrible pour
niall sûrement mettre une tour en 1 8
après tu es tu y prends il y avait la
dame en h7
mial en pleine forme et dominer la
différence de niveau est béante allez
juste plus fort mais bon juste cliquer
sur les lots max chez ce gamin de façon
si on veut que ce soit en blitz ou en
eau en bullet et on va vite voir lequel
est censé être plus forts 1
alors on inhale sarine blitz classement
max 3120 bullet 3380 smirnov blitz 3059
donc 60 points de moins bullet de 1941
donc 400 points de moins dans ce format
l'ania l'essence être plus forts après
après le match up la forme comment se
passe un match alors c'est une
compétition amicale il ya fait y'a pas
grand chose à gagner à part de l'argent
et non il n'y a pas de points gagnés
comme au tennis aux arènes compétition
par internet ne sont pas classés
je pense à faire tour f 1,8 mais il doit
être en pression avec l'attak qui arrive
sur son roi tout cas la saint antoine
qui se met mal autant
je vous des quatre alors sur cd il veut
tour à ses huit ça c'est logique et sur
ed je vous avoue ne pas comprendre
arrivée au pouvoir m le quart ayant
maintenant je sais pas il veut empêcher
à tour de revenir peut-être ma sphère
tour c'est 8
c'est lui qui à un moment de flottement
en tonnes il joue très lentement
il vient de claquer deux minutes de là
dedans il a pas il a pas de rythme là il
s'est hissé perdu dans la position même
en égalité matérielle il veut faire dame
ces deux échanges et les dames après il
ya un gros centre un côté blanc ça fait
peur ça avance
allez faut qu'on y aille la gagne celle
là
cavalli c7 qui veut cavaliers des 5 et
cavaliers c3 et il anticipe un peu le d5
position et complexe fragile car elle
arrive en c3 il a tu as quand même
beaucoup de pièces adverse plus que 28
secondes pour nihal là ils bloquent de
nouveau les dames 17 jouer vite
ag il va peut-être pas reprendre mais là
il semble qu'on puisse prendre et sur
qualifié 3 faire un gamin pour avoir
dame g7 maths ça donne bien envie faut 5
aussi voilà antoine jean besson qui l'a
vraiment très mal jouer cette partie
c'est bien fait pour le fut au final un
peu ce qu'ils payent le fait de ne pas
avoir temporisé le scénario de match lui
demander de faire nul il allait chercher
quelque chose dont ils n'avaient pas
besoin et il va payer le prix cash en
faisant surtout une très mauvaise partie
enfin très mauvaise il génère peut-être
mais en faisant une partie peu
qualitative avait quand même beaucoup de
pions maintenant pour pour nihal il va
échanger les dames c'est bien joué et il
a gagné le pion b gratuitement en plus
laurent tonnes qui va récupérer 17 qui
lui est donnée cadeaux par nial encore
une gaffe il y en a vraiment beaucoup 1
pour des joueurs de ce niveau alors là
il bloque parce qu'il peut pas laisser
les changes des tours et ça fait trois
pions - et c'est perdu
mehal qui revient un peu au score il
peut dire un grand merci à antonne anton
qui s'étire après il commençait par
aladdin fois ils avaient vraiment baissé
le pied un pour lui commençait à 3h30 du
matelas je crois il avait un peu baissé
et le pied dans la deuxième partie ça va
se jouer à celui qui résiste le mieux au
sommeil je pense ce match c'est
intéressant du coup ça rajoute une
dimension à ces matchs en fait de faire
jouer tard la nuit par le soir à l'heure
où les joueurs doivent normalement ça
rajoute un peu de un peu de piment et
c'est tout ce qu'on sait tout ce qu'on a
je vais être une petite page de pub et
on reviendra dans cinq six minutes après
la pause
j'espère que vous avez bien aimé ce
cette première partie de match et on va
revenir pour une heure de match après la
pause à tout égard
à
par avec harnais de retour
on est de retour les gars
dans nos pronostics bât signal joue
toujours aussi mal victoire dans tonnes
même si je pense qu'il est
intrinsèquement moins fort mais n'y al
maler de trêve à jouer ce soir
la procédure anti anti triche way sont
tellement marrant et procédures anti
triche à l'ue par l'islande eyes tel le
fonds marée les procédures anti triche
elles me font marrer
elles me font marrer les monsois peter
ça repartira pour une heure vermette le
chrono
on va repartir pour une heure de match
sajjadi dans le var de niall ouais je
pense à le soulever vrai salaire de le
saouler en vrai
après ces longs ainsi femme ne va pas
reparler pour la 50e ou centième fois de
la même chose va pas reparler de la
centième fois de la même chose allez on
va envoyer du chrono je vais pouvoir le
remettre à l'écran voilà donc des cas de
jouer cavalier avis si ces quatre
américains et un tueur stockfisch dans
la même pièce ouais tu parce qu'ils
essayent attrape d'attraper avec le
retour de 360 dans la chambre en fait
parce que de toute façon moi je vois
qu'ils ont leurs micros qui sont éteints
donc s'il y avait quelqu'un qui leur
parlait à voix haute en fait on
n'entendrait pas en fait l'audio est pas
et pas vérifié donc s'il avait juste une
enceinte avec quelqu'un qui leur dit les
coups il y aurait aucun moyen de le
vérifier
donc je ne comprends vraiment pas même
si t'es qu'une enceinte avait même pas
besoin d'un rein y'a même pas besoin
d'une oreillette ou quoi même pas besoin
d'écouteurs ou quoique ce soit il
pourrait avoir juste une enceinte
quelque part dans une autre pièce ou
même dans la même pièce enfin n'importe
où en fait caché sous le lit ou
n'importe où bath est indétectable et
justes et juste quelqu'un qui aura
allemand die les coûts m'ont encore une
autre manière de réussir à contourner
le les mails et les failles il ya
tellement de méthodes différentes pour
contourner le truc c c'est
impressionnant
c'est un vrai c'est pour ça que m peu
importe ça me fait penser aux
vérifications des moteurs sur le tour de
france qui en fait verrier qui en fait
ça fonctionne pas vraiment ils sont très
légères ça va choper les trucs les plus
les plus odieuses mais contre quelqu'un
qui a qui fait un peu d'effort le moteur
va réussir à être cachés dans le vélo
près quand même plus de risques parce
que du coup le moteur on peut le trouver
là y'a aucun risque de se faire choper
en plus ce qui rend la chose encore plus
simple vélo il suffit de faire une chute
un truc un machin et le vélo peut se
faire on sait pas peut y avoir des
problèmes
il prend la case 5 s'est de nouveau à
une structure carlsbad
ouais j'ai eu des nouveaux motards dans
les vélos maintenant il s'était caché
dans les roues j'ai vu que maintenant il
est caché dans les roues yaris à faire
des moteurs qu'ils intègrent dans la
roue il intègre des moteurs dans la roue
et ce qu'il fait il ya même une image
comme ça sur à tous on peut retrouver la
vidéo sur youtube où il ya un coureur
qui tombe est en fait tout d'un coup le
vélo est par terre et sa route mais a
démarré à tourner très vite
du coup il cache un nom dans les roues
ça c'est une méthode
c'est pas le pédalier qui s'emballent
c'est la route tout seul en fait le
pédalier lui bouge pas c'est la roue qui
commence à tourner et oui aussi eu des
pédaliers qui s'emballe et oui il ya
aussi mais je veux pour parler du truc
de la roue en fait c'est indépendant du
reste
l'inventeur il est hongrois ray
parce pas une théorie complotiste du
coup nawak il ya même des reportages
très sérieux il ya même eu un reportage
de stade 2 là dessus c'est très très
sérieux en sait mais ya pas vraiment les
moyens pour pour stopper ces trucs là
vous avez la réponse de petrossian
message de saut non tu peux m'envoyer à
bobby fischer ça m'intéresse ça tu peux
mettre un lien ça m'intéresse
envoyé sur une distance je vais aller
regarder ça c'est intéressant sa
position à la liste un peu se dérouler
attendez je suis en train de lire ça
c'est génial sa réponse
foncez
en anglais pour rien
c'est génial invite à un match avec dix
mille dollars en winner takes it all
quoi
défoncer il a défoncé wesley so en
position latérale de sécurité en gros
pour faire simple il dit que c'est une
petite fille qui qui qui pleurent dans
ses mains et qui fait pipi dans ces pans
perse quoi il l'a défoncé une petite
fille qui pleure et qui fait pipi dans
ses pompes hertz croit il a fait très
très mal souvent position latérale de
sécurité qua non il propose un match sur
l'échiquier réel avec 5000 $ chacun il a
dit je te défonce des personnes pour moi
j'ai battu des joueurs beaucoup plus
fort que toi tu n'existes pas quoi il a
défoncé wes les sauts en position
latérale de sécurité des amis non là il
a défoncé en vrai moi je propose
octogone moi je propose de faire un
octogone sont retrouvés morts ce qui va
prendre très très cher je viens ce week
end à colmar
non mais c'est bien répondu de la part
de petrosyan n'ya pas se laisser marcher
dessus il a envoyé là aucune chance sans
réelle ben on va voir on va voir si sow
accepte un on va voir si soit accepte un
normalement tu acceptes un aller-retour
b1 trouver un qui va arriver rapidos et
c'est gagné
niall qui se réveille anton qui m'a payé
sa mauvaise décision un solde des fonds
sur un vrai chic et peut-être aux échecs
mais je pense que si ça commence à
partir en octobre ghosn 1
est-ce que ça devra jouer aux échecs
quoi ce qui pourrait s'en faire coller
une belle bref ça peut ça peut partir
dans des choses qui peuvent être
intéressantes la seconde l'échiquier
dans la figure ça va lui faire du bien
quoi ouais
tout cas on attend on attend on attend
une réponse de saut il ya un lien mais
en gros il se fait juste insulté pendant
quinze lignes so so il se fait jusqu'à
insulter sur quinze lignes
franchement ça m'aurait pas plu un soin
répondu tu as atteint lien est bobby
fischer tu peux être sûr discorde
attendez je vais mais je vais regarder
ça avec avec le redis je suis obligé de
regarder les gars c'est trop intéressant
c'est dans les commentaires d'articles
ou c ou
ouais ok il a répondu qu'il était ok de
le jouer assure un vrai chic est
soit accepté ça va être chaud
beau c'est beau ça par sa part en
insultes j'aime bien
bon par contre mon avoir un c'est
important ça et c'est beau quoi sa part
en accusation sans fondement sa part en
insultes c'est génial
hiré boubakary c'est vrai mais sauf que
sauf que ça va jamais en arriver aux
mains quoi grâce à ça pourrait serait
pas très loin de partir en baston
tracerait bo qui se rencontrent à orly
tout cas ça me chauffe cette histoire ça
manquait de drama ouais ouais si si
après il veut leur porte à la cpi il
écrit je vais être aux portes à la fidh
mais en vrai en vrai c'est petrossian
qui peut intenter un procès contre
contre west les soit à mon avis ça peut
ça peut aller très très loin à cette
histoire
ben on magnifie tu as tu vois pas trouvé
ça suspicieux enfin c'est toujours
pareil en fait ces compétitions sur
internet vous prenez ça trop au sérieux
c'est comme quand vous était là en mode
hikaru super fort ou mvl ont su heure
assez bien joué ça faut prendre plus on
prend aussi ce qui est prend 1,6 il sait
il s'est réveillé niall sarine suis
parce qu'il avait il avait un problème
mais là il s'est réveillé il fait très
mal c'est plus ce à quoi on s'attendait
telus situera sur internet n'ont aucune
valeur en fait et le fait de leur donner
de la valeur
on se retrouve dans des situations comme
comme celle de petrossian et sow ici
qu'ils s'amendent des life les deux
allez moi j'étais sûr que l'arménie
allait gagner mais j'étais je suis
premier à dire ma magnifique chasse je
savais qu'ils allaient gagner en fait
très fort sur internet jamais dit
d'anvers moi je le dis depuis le début
mais je vais pas faire des posts sur
internet je m'en fiche
c'est comme tout le monde qui te dit
maintenant que hikaru au numéro un
mondial bis plus ou moins à égalité avec
carlson va on va voir quand ça va
reprendre sur des vraies échiquier moi
j'ai l'impression qu'ils kharouba parme
va pas participer au prochain candidat
mais après je me trompe peut-être c'est
pareil en fait autant que je pense que
les arméniens ont gagné tous les
tournois et tout ça enfin je donne pas
d'importance à ces tournées en fait je
m'en fiche c'est ce que je vous explique
depuis le début c'est pour ça que j'aime
pas c'est on a sur internet parce que
l'on peut pas savoir donc du bon con
c'est pas moi c'est tout je le dis à
chaque fois c'est pas on regarde on les
joue pour s'amuser ce comme les title
tune zeït vois je les joue et puis je
m'en fiche en fait mais je tire pas de
conclusions sur sur quoi que ce soit bah
non mais je pense pas qu'ils caroux
triche mais je veux dire pas pourquoi
les âmes et les arméniens sont plus
suspicieux que les uns que les autres
enfin c'est tout ça n'a aucune
importance car où il fait il fait ses
tours en effet c'est tout on verra bien
ça s'ajuste pas d'importance trucs sur
internet
le problème c'est qu'il ya du fric en
jeu
ouais ça c'est le problème de la plate
forme c'est le joueur il accepte d'y
jouer il accepte de jouer c'est tout
enfin là il ya vingt mille dollars en
jeu si tu prends les tournois du magnus
tour et tout ça il ya plus de 300000
euros qui ont été empochés donc c'est un
peu plus que vingt mille balles
icra claouey il se fait défoncer laurent
tonnes le problème c'est juste que tout
d'un coup il se réveille et comme ils
n'ont pas gagné cette année il se
réveille en disant ah ouais peut-être ça
triche et ça n'a pas commencé depuis
hier un sait depuis le début que l'on
dit y'a aucune vérification comme ce
tournant là comme ce match à aucune
vérification de rien donc fallait réagir
avant et justement quand magnifique chef
et il me dit ouais mais toi tu as dis
depuis le début de la compétition que
les arméniens allait gagner moi j'ai pas
attendu de perdre en finale pour dire
qu'ils allaient gagner qu'ils étaient
très très fort j'ai tout de suite dit
dès le début qu'il était très très fort
mais j'ai vu qu'il était très très fort
enfin voilà c'est tout
c'est tout mais après à ce petit jeu là
on peut soupçonner absolument tout le
monde et je vois pas pourquoi y'a que
les arméniens qui trinquent en fait ça
qui m'énerve
y a pas plus de preuves pour eux que
pour quelqu'un de là c'est intéressant
ce qu'il a fait en tonnes ce qui l'a
ramené son roi il a très mal joué la
finale ni alain il va se prendre le lion
il va la perdre en fait mais n'importe
quoi de perdre cette finale c'est
n'importe quoi de perdre une finale
comme ça moi qui aime bien les belles
finales
je suis déçu damache d'amd ça il va
peut-être la tenir quand même ouais elle
va quand même tenir du bout des doigts
parce que l'arménie est plus haut plus
que les autres
les sommes en jeu sont bien moindres
j'ai pas vu tout le monde gueule et
candou bof a gagné un magnus tour ou
quoi il va tomber il n'y aurait personne
à gueuler quand double offre à gagner un
magnus tour c'est tant mieux pour lui
j'ai rien fait j'ai en fait on s'en fout
on peut pas savoir ya pas de
vérification masse et c'est le seul
argument que je veux apporter c'est
c'est tout en fait c'est qu'il n'y a pas
de vérification on peut on peut tous
parlé à tort et à travers de tout le
monde ça apportera rien ça n'apportera
rien
le principe du haut rhin de la zététique
ce qui a fait râler sans preuve peut
être réfutée sans preuves exactement ce
qu'il faudrait en fait c'est que ça
aille vers un truc plus constructif moi
ce que je trouve dommage c'est que sa
part en débat sa part en débat intel a
triché tous à machin sans fondement
au lieu de deux alors au lieu de donner
des solutions pour que cypress avait
plus lieu en fait ça qui m'énerve c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'il faut c'est juste des
parties entre ordinateurs non mais le
problème c'est que ce n'est pas
constructif
ce n'est pas constructif et c'est très
sélectif sur les personnes et et il
s'attaque aux personnes les plus faibles
et les plus faciles à attaquer est ce
qu'il ya des solutions à bail en est une
qui est simple de solutions de la
solution que je donne depuis déjà trois
ans c'est de mettre de jouer soit dans
des clubs ensemble ou dans des lieux où
il ya du monde donc sur les paris games
week où des événements comme ça ou bien
d'avoir un arbitre dans la pièce avec le
joueur donc il y a des solutions
et au lieu de parler à tort et à travers
et d'accuser la terre entière
sow il ferait mieux d'apporter quelque
chose de constructif et de proposer des
solutions
là on est dans un cas de figure où on a
pas on donne pas les armes pour pouvoir
vérifier quoi que ce soit donc mais la
caméra ça change rien les caméras ça
sert à rien
il est cramé race approuvera jamais rien
ça prouve absolument rien regardez là
comme je vous dis les micros des joueurs
sont éteints il suffirait que sur le
haut parleur de leur ordinateur il est
quelqu'un qui parlait il aurait les
coûts oralement
ça sert à rien oulala qui a valu aux
cinq essais 4 et pourquoi c'est pas fait
ça j'en sais rien à voir pourquoi c'est
pas fait ça j'arrive pas à comprendre
mais ah c'est ça la question quoi cela
il doit poser la vraie question c'est ça
la vraie question c'est pas d'aller
chialer sur sur les arméniens n'est ni
mineur ni le tri chez nadine avec quelle
preuve avec zéro preuve
le truc c'est de dire s'il ya pas de
vérification l'an prochain plus sérieuse
sur les joueurs je ne participe plus à
la compétition au point barre faut
assumer jusqu'au bout un sait tous ici
là il a calé au bout de son propos
c'est ça la vraie chose qui peut chanter
ça qui peut faire bouger les choses
c'est pas 2 c'est pas d'aller dire à
anton machin tu dis ok cette année j'ai
des soupçons sur les arméniens je peux
rien prouver j'ai des soupçons sur les
joueurs arménien pour un bar tu vas pas
plus loin tu dis mais on peut rien
prouver donc bravo à eux belle victoire
cependant si l'année prochaine des
mesures ne sont pas prises pour
s'assurer que tout le monde joue sur un
pied d'égalité
je ne participerai plus à cette
compétition et envoie ton mail et point
barre et c'est tout les point barre et
on en parle plus était dans le respect
d'autrui et et dans le respect d'autrui
tu écris ça et puis on n'en parle plus
c'était difficile de faire un événement
sans arrêt voilà vous avez voulu prendre
tout l'argent et les milliers de lés
millions d'euros qui étaient donnés dans
des compétitions sur internet
d'accord vous avez pris plein d'argent
pour redresser compétition vous êtes
vous vous savez que n'importe qui peut
tricher qu'il sera jamais détectés et
ben voilà c'est tout fin du problème fin
du problème parce que dans des
compétitions où il est si facile de
tricher tous ceux qui gagnent seront
toujours soupçonné
à la haye la case d3 l'aïe a tout vu vu
que c'est élémentaire à faire et que c'
est indétectable
n'importe quel joueur qui va remporter
un peu des compétitions sera forcément
suspect donc il ya pas bon
ben c'est pas forcément ce sujet négatif
nawak 1 c'est un sujet d'actualité plus
que négatif voilà il va perdre le pion
c3 et la partie avec al qaîda peut-être
aller en e2 pour gagner en tempo
quant à eux deux il ya peut-être fou et
3,1 meilleur af459 ses trois métiers
prend 1,2 et fort aux siens en
l'attaquant même le foie f4
intermédiaire séparé sympa d'accord le
champ de l'isf invitationnal veut
sûrement l'année prochaine n'aura qu'à
on va pas en faire tout les mois non
plus hein pas l'intérieur f4 et c3 ces
deux bons yala qui a l'air quand même
d'être largement au dessus maintenant de
d'antonne ce avec des qui se rapproche
un peu de son niveau de jeu et remonte
alors laquelle il va jouer et voir jouer
qui et b17 sûrement la cambridge fring
est la prochaine se battaient les
couilles a plus personne qui veut
vraiment jouer de cette battle je crois
que c'est sorti mode
je crois que c'est sorti de mode même
nous on en avait un peu marre en vrai on
trouvait même plus de joueurs pour jouer
sa mère d'être sorti de mode
ça viendra peut-être à la mode plus tard
il reste combien de temps environ alors
attends on a notre premier truc qui
arrive 37 37 minutes de 3 + 1 et après
on aura le bullet
perso je pense vraiment que ça triche
pas on sera prêt je me trompe peut-être
mais j'ai pas du tout l'impression
oui mais de façon peut pas savoir donc
c'est même pas la peine d'y penser en
fait
c'est ça en fait le truc cette façon
s'est pas vérifiée tu peux pas savoir
donc sert à rien d'y penser même il
semble que non et puis voilà
il semble que non mais voilà un
donc
vous prend b2 tour ces deux fous prend
1,5 ou proches cet intermédiaire et
dames c2c bien joué ça
alors ces qualités contre un pion
on va faire dame des quatre noms pour
gagner la fois attaquer le roi je pense
que la dame elle vend des 4es h 5 h h 4
h 5 h 6 ça doit être le plan alors après
il faut bien calculer
parce qu'il faut que tu arrivé avant les
pions tu parles changer de répertoire et
ongles andré la scandinave pour revenir
à la carro canin pas du tout j'ai pas du
tout joué à carreaux cannes
je déteste cette ouverture je vais jouer
quatre cinq six changé
je penserai d'accord il veut h4 il veut
dams et 5h quatre dames ces cinq dames f
4g calculerait dans cette direction là
mais après c'est pas dit que ça marche
mais j'aurais envie d'attaquer le roi
parce que sur cases noires ça peut faire
très mal
fort à six il veut forcer tours à huit
et partir pour h4 peut-être à ce moment
là où il a une autre idée sur tours à
8,1 il a peut-être à quatre billets tout
reprend ses 4
des douanes vaisselle c'est hyper
compliqué là et c'est l'apparence de
francs femmes françaises que j'aime pas
à ces ouvertures france à jacques j'aime
pas avoir peu d'espacé en fait
du coup j'ai joué beaucoup avec peu d
espace dans ma vie mais est temps de
changer
alors surtout racette
il veut dame f3 et fouet est fou c'est 6
la française pas si compliqué mais fort
envie de jouer avec peu d espace aussi
faire dame prend à 7 c'est vraiment
compliqué tu sens que tu dois être mieux
avec les blancs est parti pour le plan
d'attaqué la halle dame sur 4 5 t à
beaucoup d'ouverture à connaître ouais
oui et non oui oui tu as beaucoup
d'ouverture à connaître son jeu je
connais jamais la théorie très loin donc
d'un prochain qu'il veut quand il veut
d'amd 4
par exemple il ya quoi de bien contre
2,4 marbré de toutes les ouvertures sont
pas là car aux cats pas mal pour débuter
la petrov je pense va faire f4 ici non
tu peux tu as fait bien sûr cases noires
parce que l'autre n'a pas de fous de
cases noires tour des isles autour des 8
d'accord c'est pas idiot ça il veut
échanger secrète si les changes les
pièces lourdes
il restera avec la tour ensuite qui
bloque rapion il montera le roi et
chopra les pions et tourne assez bien
joué l'idc tour des huit
puisque s'inquiète un coût non il fait
froid il va faire tour des huit là c'est
sûr et la question c'est ce que la
finale quand le roi montant de 7 mais la
tentation repartir en d1 le roi venir
par là elle doit aller je pense tour des
huit ça doit aller ils échangent mais la
tour d un j'aime bien pour dire j'aime
beaucoup
tourbes et 8 pouces et 6 il faut
calculer comment le roi monté il a dû
calculer si son roi arrive en c3 ça va
il a peut-être un petit coup de a3 ici
ouais pour empêcher roye b 4 c'est bien
joué et roi des deux c'est trois rois
c'est un droit c'est de il est fou 4 sur
échec ça j'aime pas le fou qui va venir
en d3 bon alors attendez voilà avec peu
de temps et hyper chaude à jouer il me
dit menace roi b3 peut-être web et trois
tours à huit tours à huit importants
ouais tour des huit ok mais tour à 8
après je pense pas qu'ils doivent
laisser le pion à 3 mais oui il a perdu
g4 pourquoi il n'a pas fait tour à 8
direct à la la c'est terrible c'est
terrible ces terres il joue pas les
coups les plus logiques quoi passer
durant les finales c'est très dur les
finales il joue pas les coups les plus
logiques il joue pas le placement de
pièces logique et va le payer
il va probablement j'allais dire pas la
perdre mais c'est pas sûr et bien c'est
tellement important que voulait couler
plus logique en finale dans le fou qui
va arriver à f/5 il peut faire b3 il
pouvait faire des trois tours france et
3 b 2 et là il se prend h5 pas possible
c'est mike avec les noirs
merci ça
ce que j'aime bien les finales mais là
il se prend perpète
il aurait pu faire tout rage 3 peut-être
essayer de passer trop là la terrible
après il avait peu de temps mais
décevant l'a77 finale de la part des
deux hommes
les finales c'est que du placement de
pièces et de l'apprentissage mais là
avec leur vitesse de calcul il aurait
quand même pu faire mieux
du coup niall qui jouent des français
car il va jouer une bobine hic c'est
marrant ça vous allez voir ça donne des
positions marrante
ça donne des positions marrante mais
après c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui doivent
tellement à apprendre de théories n'ont
pas forcément le temps de faire des
finales à fond salah une chiée de
théorie il n'y a pas d'autre mot
près la part au prix le pion f6 que tu
as un problème avec le clouage bas ça
c'est hyper théorique ça a été hyper
analyser ça ça a été très très analyse
est quasiment sûre qu'ils connaissent
plus ou moins encore
faire craquer c3 et gagne la qualité non
il va falloir reprendre de la dame et
envoyait son calvaire f3 c'est compliqué
ces trucs
les 305 qui en avaient tous les mois et
ça marchait pas très bien d'ailleurs
après vous pouvez les organiser entre
vous aussi sur le discorde etc
ouais ça a l'air d'être dangereux pour
les blancs ce truc la f3c bien joué donc
à quoi et la qualité de plus mais y'a
position mais vraiment ultra dangereuse
ya ça qui peut être en l'air il ya lui
qui est faible quand même enfin qui est
fait qu'ils attaquent et assayas
il ya beaucoup de choses ouverte mais
après après un coup comme dames 4 en
fait la pression il peut se renverser
c'est chaud
belle case d3 aussi ouais mais après il
ya un truc qui est hyper dangereux
exposition peut alors jouer avec les
noirs des fois tu as l'impression que tu
as de la tacc tas de l'attak tout d'un
coup tu as deux fins d'un petit truc qui
s'échangent apprête à h 5 h si ce qui
arrive est le pion âge peut être très
pénible à stopper aussi je pense que les
blancs sont mieux en réalité j'aime
beaucoup tout rêve d un
ce genre les coûts qui peuvent être
pénibles tadam 4 qui peut faire mal pour
échanger les dan sa b3 savard d'être
très bien pour les blancs ça
ça m'a l'air très bien pour les blancs
il propose b 3 pour les noirs ouais
c'était pas idiome ça aussi c'est pas
idiot autour des 8
c'est interdit b3 parce que maintenant
on peut prendre ces positions qui sont
très durs à jouer c'est un vraiment pour
les deux joueurs près le succès qu'avec
les blanches tu survis tu as
l'impression que tu va la gagner mais
d'un autre côté ce que tu vas là
survivre et les noirs peuvent aussi
s'ils réussissent à bien avancer les
pions créer un contre au jeu difficiles
et afu des 4 6 mai françois dac
attention et surtout des cas d'opa soit
un tour prend des trois prises des trois
prises détroit et se faire retourner
dans lequel j'ai cas tout à l'heure
d'around menacé pas du tout cavalier 3
pascal fou g5 qui marche les fous vont
en arrière aussi ce qui permettait de
défendre qui fait roi b6 qui a une tête
de truc logique puisqu'il veut préparer
à 5 et peut-être dans une finale qui
arrive à voir le roi bien placé tonnes
qui met son poids et son fils est très
moche hein alors quelle horreur ce pull
c'est terrible oh c'est terrible on peut
plus regarder en ont vraiment horrible
ce fut le nom qui fait h 5 h 5 ça paraît
tellement stupide
il a juste donné un pion en 1 je pense
qu'il n'a pas vu les dames des cinq
ouais alors le pull est vraiment pas
terrible qui nous infligent ce pull et
donc l'annoncé
voir qu'ils sont mieux parce qu'ils ont
plus facilement un pion passé qui se
dessine encore que g4 g5 un g6 ça va
vite on va faire un quatrain évidemment
est sûre j'ai 5 à 3 les deux joueurs
vont essayer de créer leurs pions passer
ça va être tendu mais le truc c'est
quand le pion vient en b2 il y aura dame
de dame prend c'est peut-être peut-être
dame f5 ici ouais mais ça doit être nul
du coup ouais aux 5 c'est le coup
logique aussi alors risque d'un f4 et
une menace il va prendre là nul avec les
blancs alors nihal qui veut pas deux
nuls
il ya plus d'échec il veut il veut faire
d'un f4
il va faire d'un f4 ici non il veut
partir avec le roi là bas dans ses
hypers chose qu'il est en train de faire
ça se passe très bien joué parce que sur
dame d2 il ya plus d'échecs et son roi
va couvrir d'un f4
le roi va monter damages de roy g4 d'un
f4 roi ici et là pas mieux que nulle
sûrement ouais il n'y a pas mieux que
nulle joli final de la part des deux
hommes très bien joué de la part de
niall pour mettre la pression
je vais développer il va faire f 4k et
la joue pas il a rejoint comme ça les
rues dames c'est toi il avait été un
poil mieux après des c4
je me souviens dames c'est de faire
passer la tour avant mes implants ça
peut être 3 f 2 tours achats ici j'aime
bien jouer ce genre de plans très
directe au moins et sur walf de frais
joseph 6e 5 rapidement
allez lâchez 4g 5 direct sans réfléchir
donc
kiev 5 g 5 quand même et il va avoir la
petit avantage à long terme du bon fou
contre le mauvais fou le bon foot case
blanche contre le mauvais faux en face
là maintenant on relève de tout rachat
est beaucoup plus fort parce qu'on peut
plus ouvrir le centre cadre de son âge
alors braves en avant avant le match
j'étais sûr que niall sarine à l
emporter facilement près genre sont
signalés pas très enfants dont je me
suis peut-être trompé mais bon
pourquoi pas
chère entré sur âge c'est une option
mais je pense qu'il veut pas échanger il
réfléchit est-ce que c'est grave de
d'échangés le fou conclut cavaliers là
le truc sur france 3 il avait pu
comprendre pions pranger set et là ils
menacent vous prend et cavaliers cinq
dons qui provoque prise prise il va
vouloir faire ça ça ça ça et ça
mais les noirs doivent doivent blindés
ils vont avoir le temps de blindés il
aurait peut-être dû faire wave 2 plutôt
niall au lieu des 5 au lieu de d'un coup
qui a joué là dans le vide
enfin dans le vide qu'est ça c'est nul
et surtout typique du stonewall us ou 17
faut une fois h5 françois jacq sur jeu
pour quelque chose france ou d'apprendre
2e essayer de fixer espions bike et noir
son plan ce qui a eu 7 kg 8 qui avait
fait escale de quatre cavaliers 7-6 8
des 6 e 4
ou qu'elle ait des huit à vii 10 6 e 4
là l'idée c'était de faire x 5 fprov 7
il va faire le plan une fois qu'il
arrive en 4 ça va complètement
il aurait pu échanger ans et 6 il est
bouillant ce match reste à jouer assez
mal là c'est cool ça permet d'avoir des
rebondissements la safer une peut-être
même pas nul au final victoire dur il
joue quand même très mal ce soir niall
sarine max il beaucoup de gaffes il est
tout le temps mal autant est il chez
phaidon il a un nom du langage corporel
assez négatif il s'est un peu repris là
mais il repart un peu dans ses travers
là encore je trouve qu'il a très mal
géré son avantage
non il va pas la perdre ça va avec les
blancs quand même pas exagérer mais
peut-être même encore la gagner mais bon
live le roi de trois des cinq essais de
fer web et trois c4 peut-être réussi la
tour doit repartir ils t'envoient des
cinq prises tour prend peut-être ou
peut-être alors pu reprendre au
printemps reprend pour ces 6 je sais pas
quoi faut reprendre
il va mettre sa tour anciens s'y
mêleront des quatre tours servent trois
des quatre enfants qui jouent un peu
plus vite quand même c'est un peu trop
mal autant
surtout au b2 il peut même y avoir des
tours des six échecs qui comprend qu on
prend au roi m6 tour des 1
roi des 4 3 6 et sur roy ces cinq là le
pion qui va partir c'est même lui qui se
retrouve moins bien finalement il va se
rendre pour detroit c'est lui qui va
devoir la défendre un tour f 3 tours f4
c'est bien joué ça dure quatre heures
guillaume pour être précis le roi en
fait si tu continues à faire les échecs
fois que j'aurai mis en g7
ouais c'est bien jouer il va devoir
faire f4 oit sur tourcoing h7 ya le pion
à qui file à dam et qui devrait être
laurent g7 maintenant et surtout à 8
ouais c'est terrible quelle faute
terrible cette finale que d'erreurs mais
là il ya eu deux maintenant que
d'erreurs à ces foules erreur terrible
et il perd la tour
ouais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'erreurs dans cette finale ce que je
disais maxime c'est un peu le festival
le festival de la gaffe à une petite
fille une petite écossaise
c'est le festival de la gaffe de voirie
schizo à souffrir un os qui doit
souffrir quand il voit çà de là où il
est
qui se rejoue son petit plan avec avec
d'amin salué bien réussi dans le match
précédent
ça arrive je rappelle qu'ils avaient
gagné une partie très facile un bled sa
rivale fumée pourrait falloir qu'il joue
un peu mieux que ça quand même un bel
s'ils continuent à jouer comme ça il
gagnera il gagnera pas c'est pas il fait
il fait trop d'erreurs il fait beaucoup
trop de fautes pour pouvoir gagner même
même même si les plus forts en bulles
est c'est pas possible
autour berry tu veux faire tourbe et
deux salades doit être égale d'un côté
il ya les noirs qui ont la tour 2e qui
est fort de l'autre côté à la mauvaise
structure de pions ça va faire nul
il veut faire tour ici meilleurs atours
gère donc il faut faire tour à 3 pour
défendre le pion et surtour deux tours
tour g1
il peut prendre à cette prendra cette
mort à tours c'est un ça va faire un
échange massif
mais la joue comme ça ah oui ce que
tanger un ses échecs parlons pas
étranger un tour à deux tours à deux
tours c'est un joueur par curiosité ça
marchait
n'est pas
il y avait un clouage je pense à des
nuls ça en fait
voilà surtout rage de il ya tout reprend
voir ça c'est nouveau les unes blanc qui
sont un peu moins bien mais n'ont
annoncé nulle facile quand même
le roi est coupée mais bon
terrible le puck dans tana tu vas où il
a trouvé
il va dans des tours à 6 je pense on
leur apprend à 4.6 ça ça doit être nul
tranquille mais il faut quand même
réfléchir qui est des quatre touristes
chaque rouage deux tours h droit
chanteur des 2 progresse pas là
quels atouts relevant des quatre sûr
essayer de gagner quand tu peux essayer
s'attendait à sa tour des quatre
autour des deux fers au f1 je pense
pourra gérer pour évider roi pour sur f3
tour échec que l'on revienne pas en f2
et lâche 4 non retour et fuit 3 f1 ouais
ouais f1 tourache 2 3g entourage trois
tours à huit ça c'est nul
tour du grand côté
et tours à huit c'est nul ouais ça c'est
facile ça rentre dans une position de
philidor bien défendu la part de niall
très bien défendu salah
fondu il retournera à cambridge sprint
du coup avec les noirs en tonnes il ya
des petits yeux le tramway mais il est
il est 4 heures du matin chez lui faut
dire que la nuit est bien avancé sur son
île continent
et il y en avait déjà jugé cette
position tout à l'heure les blancs
étaient beaucoup mieux les finis par la
perte je croise arrêts dont tout cas se
retrouver mal du coup ils rentrent dans
celle qu'on a eu à la deuxième fois avec
la qualité depuis s'il était bien et
niall aussi
fou prend h7 ici et dames ces deux dames
prend b2 il avait été bien un moment
donné si vous rappelez bien je vais
parler d'une idée 2h 4h 5h 6 à un moment
donné qui était peut-être possible je
passe était bonne d'ailleurs j'ai eu
tour ses huit tours à si tu crois
ils ont le temps de chèques alors dit
non parce que c'était déjà dans la
cadence 3 + 1 donc ils n'ont pas pu
checker sanaa
il a fait à 5 c'est mieux que ce qu'ils
avaient fait à je pense qu'ils vont
envoyer le cas il a peut-être à 4 ici
qui est intéressant ce qui a plu à 6
aussi mais je vais bien le h 4 h 5 h is
perso quand même mais bon peut-être
optimiste
est optimiste
on va voir
on va voir où ça nous mène à 4 pour toi
françois 4 ça a l'air sympa
à toi jusqu'à très lent ou l'autre
à 4
je pense qu'il est la tour en c3 à tour
d un ça va finir par une nulle ou à la
fois il refait le même plan fait retour
des 8es changé il faudra près qu'ils
fassent f4 3f devrait ça doit gagner en
fait tu fais à 3 y aura tour à 8 eshop
râle pions et sur ces trois appareils
donc là il va il va aller tout est
changé c'est sûr façon il est obligé de
prendre sinon yade à mach 4 et va se
faire mater les faits d'armes français 4
pardon j'avais oublié cette pointe sa
menace tour serra mais c'est vrai qu'on
comprend pas trop pourquoi antoine et
retourner là dedans position paraissait
juste mauvaise pour les noirs et là
normalement tu dois quand même gagné ça
surtout que je crois que le pion à il
tombe donc la faisait de la bonne
technique c'est de faire à tout
reprendre et 5 pas tout de suite
le roi est trop trop actif tête h3g qu'à
3h 2 3g 3g 3g 3 mais l'autre veut
rentrer avec son roi donc il faut faire
gaffe
là c'est un coût important peut-être
tour à quatre rois f5 tour e 1 et tours
à 4 maintenant et ça rentre dans le même
truc tour à 4 roitg trois tours f4
j'aurais pu mesurer j'aurais pas les
genres effectuera quatre ans j'aurais
pas laisser rentrer le roi quand même
nous sommes à tenter roitg 3 ayache 5
très bien joué bien joué les tours h4
matt bonne façon c'était gagné talent et
c'est bien
la part de niall ne fait pas l'autre
pendant le pendant là il veut à ludwig
soyons sérieux donc là il fait sa chair
poussette avec lecavalier a eu quatre
allez il reste combien de temps s'est il
reste en fait c'est la dernière partie
du segment
donc il ya 8 9 pour entonne s'était pas
aux talents h3 bon ouais après elle
était pâle en perdant de la finale
camara 6
ni faussement sas est réputé pour être
égal je la rends quand échanges comme ça
ça donne ses positions là j'avais dû les
étudier quand j'étais gamin ce genre de
truc jamais mais les jouets mais censés
aller
ces cinq des 5 g m6 qui a aidé cinq
têtes qui va arriver
ouais y'a pas de faiblesse du cheylard
nice et los une structure qui est censé
se tenir
je pense qu'ils aient des saints qui
sinon tu perds quand même superbe essai
de pardon faut commencer par tours
d'essai depuis qui a aidé 5 excusez moi
du coup qui a aidé 5 par an l'attenté de
faire tout recettes et qui a validé 5 du
poids pour pouvoir placer une tour sur
des cinq une tour sur 17 et envoyer la
tour là-bas pour trouver le contre jeu
si on en a besoin
kamal et h7 d'accord il part pour le
plan où il va attaquer avec qui j'ai 5
d'accord il va faire kiev 4 d'amd s'il
veut quand même cahier dé 5,1 qu'il en
soit y ont peut-être g5 qui a été 5
ça lui brise h
il va jouer avec g5 je pense
le pire est riche et des lakers parisien
je crois que c'est très possible qu'on
vit dans une simulation la probabilité
passe 6e pas si ridicule d'un v8 qui a
aidé 500 lettres une option ouais il va
échanger maintenant il va faire passer
la tour c va faire le plan et après va
faire envoyer l'eau tour
et tout ceci soit
donc il prend prend et tour g6 donc il
va envoyer le contre eux je mets là et
puis on sait si ce qui est faible
à
il part ou avec sa dame peut aller
peut-être en des huit pour partir vers
g5 peut aller verser 8 pour attaquer h3
peut faire tourbe et 7 pour échanger une
tour avant tout les coups sont possibles
non ça tient ce truc là parce que la
tour g6 elles défendent pions l attaque
g2 et le cavalier couvent la casa fca
d'autant tu dois pas perdre ça
normalement ça se tient ça malgré la
faiblesse du coup il s'est quand même
pris le truc que tu dois pas te prendre
mais ça doit tenir
mais ça doit tenir surtout maintenant
alors à temps alors dit qu'il y avait un
gain ici jordy avait juste le pion aux
quatre ans prises en vrais hommes c'est
incroyable ça quand même
il y avait jusqu'à et prend le 4 moi
aussi je rate et sur damev 5ième ok
darif 5 de toute façon c'est un clouage
tout relatif peut-être un coup comme
tour c1 et savard est et dames proches 3
ça peut jamais marché à cause de tourbe
et 8 ou même cavalier fils direct je
pense moque-t-on b8 plus simple bon ça
c'est assez primitif 1 mais ces fous qui
leur attaque avait provoqué il ya même
pas réfléchi en fait voilà ils vont
faire un nul beaucoup d'erreurs
beaucoup d'erreurs quand même dans ce
match
alors s'il veut la gagner je pense qu'il
doit et doit pousser créerait il doit
échanger eux contre des ducs ou f7
pourra pas bouger il pour envoyer le
pion des bas il va la gagner avec les
blancs c'est terrible pour ni al sarine
alors attendez peut-être qu'il faut
qu'il passe la tour là-bas nan mais
personne de dos nu pourquoi tu donnes
nul je comprends bien ce que fait
smirnov ok tu fais ça il bouge ça tours
tu fais ça par exemple est ok et
essayent de pousser il va peut-être
venir par derrière tu fais des dessins
qui fait toujours là tu fais tour c4 est
ok et essaye de la jouer tu es mieux au
temps et tu la joues je comprends pas du
tout en fait i feel prend des décisions
très bizarre smirnov ce que tu alors
déjà il se met en position d'en jouer
une de plus c'est ça fait aucun sens là
du coup ils essaient de jouer ça là il
est mieux ils arrêtent quand il a émis
de plus ces positions avantageuses
il prend il prend énormément de
décisions bizarres dans le match
smirnov après il fait ce qu'il veut un
vin moi ça ne me pose aucun problème si
vous voulez savoir mais c'est une
décision étrange
moi je vous met la petite pub et on va
se retrouver d'ici quelques petites
minutes pour pour la fin sahpresa ouais
là il ya du suspens même si seignal qui
va gagner comme prévu depuis le début du
match mais un peu de suspense mais c'est
bizarre de ne pas la jouer vraiment très
bizarre
vraiment très très bizarre
vraiment bizarre
même plus qui est extrêmement bizarre
oui après il s'en fout complètement
france n'a pas de valeur mais juste une
fois que tu joues tu joues un toit qui
joue truc ces décisions bizarres quoi
braley
il est temps d'aller faire la petite
pause à dessus les gars
je suis de retour les gars personnes sur
les rimes personnes dans le chatt rennes
tous partis match est trop intéressant
on a trop besoin de récupérer ne vous
inquiétez pas après ce match où on part
bon du coup je pas trop quoi vous dire
hein je peux regarder les résultats du
tennis un je vous dis franchement
regardez un peu ce qui s'est passé à
roland garros il tira la ligue des
champions aussi terrible terrible
ils sont où les groupes je cherchais
groupes de ligue des champions est très
intéressant vas-y aller groupe là vas-y
groupe à atletico bayern locomotive
salzburg aut il est chaud ce groupe très
chaud le premier groupe le groupe paraît
très chaud mon champ de lave d'achat
inter real shakhtar hockey groupe c
manchester city olympiakos marseille
porto et marseille sont pas très bien en
fait puisque city et porto sephora
groupe d liverpool atalante à ajax
prends ça fait trois gros clubs et
midtjylland debout midtjylland dans
sueurs groupe e chelsea krasnodar nc vie
c'est un groupe en carton ça non rennes
rennes ils peuvent passer en vrai un
chelsea
ouais bon c'est pas les plus
impressionnants sévices et pas très fort
et krasnodar pour un peu connaître le
championnat russe et c'est c'est pas
énorme
groupe f dortmund bruges lazio zénith
racée avec les groupes ils sont ils déjà
eu des rues beaucoup plus fort là groupe
e groupe f c'est pas terrible terrible
dortmund et après pour le deuxième c'est
chaud parce que l'adieu au zénith et
bruce c'est pas énorme
groupe g barcelone
kiev fenac crabos et juventus bon ben je
vais barça et istanbul bb c'est quoi ce
club istanbul bb c'est qui
c'est un nouveau club d'istanbul groupe
à istanbul manchester paris les dix cas
il est chaud ce groupe manchester marque
manchester il son carcan papier mâché
dans ce moment mais où en gros clubs
turcs c'est jamais facile les psig ils
sont forts maintenant pareil ils ont pas
un groupe si facile mais c'est un
nouveau club stambouliote n'ont jamais
entendu parler de ce club wallon va
suivre le bullet enfin que je mettre le
temps après je suis pas sûr que le match
soit assez long perso je suis un peu
déçu je suis un peu déçu de la durée de
ce match parce qu'on va pas être bien
sûr de du vainqueur 1 parce que il n'y a
qu'un point d'écart après après trois
heures de jeu et c'est vrai que ça
manque à mon avis de une petite
demi-douzaine d'heures en plus pour être
bien sûr tout cas ça commence le bullet
avec niall sarine qui affiche qui
affichent hors jeu voit pas tant défaut
que je vois bien les lola voilà je les
vois bien 400 points et l'autre plus
dans la cadence
ça fait quand même beaucoup donc ils
vont prendre ces trois prendre ces trois
prendre ces quatre prendre ces quatre
alors il joue plus vite tu n'y as assez
marrant parce qu'il n'ya là était mal
mal autant tout le long ça c'est hyper
théorique avec les deux pions sans trop
là qu'ils vont jouer contre les pions a
et b on en a vu des partis comme ça déjà
dans cette danse est tu arraches ça ça
peut arracher et là ça ait changé donc
on a le duo de pions face au faso pions
parce éloignées possibles peut avoir des
idées de dessins que cinq parfois
attention à cavaler b2en ici qui
menacent et de de prendre le fou de
cases blanches qui est une pièce
primordial des blancs et là où est donc
cette idée de dessins qui on prend 1,5
et ramener en des cats attaqué le roi
qui est récurrente dans la position tour
bien il s'en prend aux cavale il va
mettre la tour en b3 maintenant et
peut-être des 5,5 maintenant c'est
peut-être le moment de faire des prises
et e5 et ça va être le moment d'envoyer
exactement sur des quatre cavaliers à
des cats étaient peut-être intéressant
puisqu'elle cavalier va venir en d4
maintenant et peut-être poussé 5 pouces
et 5 e 6 ou prend des 4 7 6 avait l'air
fort aux cavaliers car élèves 5 très
bien joué et puis on prend avec 5 fu pro
f 5 tours j'ai trois dames h5
allez on sent que nialé un gros joueur
de bullet mais smirnov qui jouent eux
qui poussent le plus en d4 et peut-être
six maintenant là mais aussi ce marcheur
et +1 parce que cette serait couvert par
le food qui l'a fait dame g4 il propose
des menaces est peut-être un fou g5 afu
g5 qui avait acheté soit 6
est ce que ça marche de mettre leur dit
je mets le petit ordi l'ordi qui
s'allume pas le petit ordi qui s'allume
pas les gars mais fou g5 pierre l'air
fort il a fait fou prend b3 il a pris la
tour qui avait lié h6 du coup droit
roger sais c'est dur ce que moi j'essaie
tu vas te remettre sur du cavaliere 5
alors est ce qu'il fait fouet je pense
fouet f6 damev 6 juin m6 comme ça
talpiot f6 bien placé ah non il prend il
veut dame j'ai cinq dames f6 maths alors
il va faire dame g5 ou d'un mach 4
roady a peut-être f 5 5 puis on prend
tout re ya f5 où il ya tour g7 les deux
sont possibles
il envoie et tour des six le fou en b3
est bien placé pour défendre
cependant qu'à et gk très bien joué un
an phu pranger 6 et on va tout faire
péter
aya pie vii encore ff7 été un coup quand
même en réalité puisque fou prend à
rêver d'un match 7 f7 maintenant du coup
il ya tout reprend tours 7
ouais mais fou prend 1,7 à fouquereuil 7
puis on prend 1,7 tour 8es dame f6 maths
c'est bien joué
tous rêvent cette déformation peut-être
tours 8 non il a fait tout reprend cf
cet emprunt f7 et ya peut-être un
camaïeu 5 maintenant qui menacent kg 6
matt well as i là il a tout envoyé kg si
ce matin à c'est gagné ça fait ça fait
1-0 dans les bulles est pour pour notre
ami niall qui qui recolle immédiatement
au score
il ya deux nouveaux égalité dans ce
match et la partie numéro deux est parti
d'un fait neuf et demi et directement ni
al sarine qui fait parler la supériorité
en bullet ça finalement peut-être se
joue en bullet ans ce match il y aura eu
les trois heures de match au début et
merci à freeman pour le sahb il y aura
u13 à trois petites heures au début pour
bien s'échauffer et puis tout se joue
après ans en bullet c'est fantastique
c'est vraiment intéressant donc là il va
peut-être y avoir un cavalier si ce
projet cadre des quatre rapide
j'imagine que c'est encore théorique
mais la voilà peut-être envoyé depuis en
d4 vite fait voilà ces essais réalisés
et les blancs qui jouent aux quatre fous
j'ai quatre donc maintenant le pion et
est isolé mais il est passé et on va
pouvoir venir un peu ta qu'ils n'aillent
et le pion à eux quatre en cas de besoin
et essayer de pousser notre pions des et
merci à freeman pour pour le sabot faire
allez ça envoie il ya eu 5 y avait
peut-être une petite dame en d5
il semble là vraiment que ce soit
dominant maintenant pour pour notre ami
pour notre ami sarine qui m'a l'air
d'être tellement plus forts en bulles
est hélas peut-être fou prend 1,5
sky prend tu peux pas tout reprend mais
fou prend un tour prend ses six fours en
g3 semblait marcher
tondez 8 c'est très bien aussi au niveau
des trois il faut prendre 5 toujours
encore et toujours bis repetita il va il
va faire faut prendre cinq cavaliers
prendre 5 ouais ça attaque la dame m'a
non c'est tout à fait tout à fait
possible aussi ses pions plusieurs fois
f6 g5
il va faire [ __ ] quatre tours prend à
eux deux pour prendre 2 pouces et 7
peut-être pour se réorganiser g5 aussi
mais poussé sa tête pour réussir à avoir
du fou b6 pour protéger c'est chose
faite le fou qui va venir en b6
maintenant la difficulté c'est de passer
sur sur détroit
ce qui va être difficile c'est d'avancer
le pion maintenant peut-être devoir
faire des tours 8 c'est bien jouer il va
échanger mais cette position doit être
nul hein je pense pas que quel soit
fondamentalement gagnante mais bon tu
affaire d'âme des 5 tu va pousser petit
top 5
ces avantages noir quand même après
va-t-il va-t-il le réaliser c'est moins
sûr mais en tout cas ils continuent à
presser c'est ça qui est important pour
lui c'est de pressé toutes les parties
il va mettre la dame en c3 alors
attention l'un d'eux paf se faire
rentrer d'am dam des cinq j'adore parce
qu'on protège beaucoup de cases on
prépare des trois la dame qui doit
revenir on peut pas laisser des trois
mon avis fois cette île va essayer de
chercher un
il temporise il va essayer de chercher
quelque chose
le cavaly qui part vers eux quatre ils
fait pas grand chose peut-être un dame 5
hir parents et quatre avec le fou
évidemment qui a aidé de fou prend des
deux il serait très heureux il veut
peut-être des f-5 ben c'est bien ce
qu'il fait parce qu'en fait ils bougent
sans trop de plans et maintenant dame c4
et oui maintenant que tu as fait bk tu
donnes avec la casse ces quatre c'est le
craquage g5y tient le fou et ça va
avancer et d'apprendre
ati gagne le lion peut alors il ya un
petit échec qui a deux petits échecs il
va y avoir g6 et la dame qui revient en
c4 est tranquillement qui défend qui
défend f7 eia le pion des qui va filer
tranquillement adam et ça va faire plus
sain pour sarine là c'est inéluctable le
pion qui part en d2 voilà y'a rien à
faire hein les gars surtout pas d'armes
français 5 pour éviter les échecs mais
juste des deux quoique même peut-être ça
marchait et la dap adams et indiens
marche toujours pas dame prend 1,4
marche pas brimer fait d un échec est en
prend 4 oui pardon dans ce temps là ça
marche chez dams et 4 le retour et le
pion béquille par la haye mais à trop
d'écart en bullet trop d'écart pour ça
que vous disais tout à l'heure
s'il avait pris l'avantagé rapidement
dans le match comme je le prévoyais
aniane sainz aurait pu faire un gros
score moi j'avais annoncé minimum +6 je
m'étais trompé je dois l'avouer mais sur
la victoire de sarine ça fait ça faisait
ça faisait peu de doute 400 points elo
d'écart même s'il était en petite forme
ou quoi c'est vraiment énorme
et là il est en train vraiment de faire
parler parler la poudre donc même dans
un scénario de match catastrophique pour
le joueur indien
il semble être beaucoup trop fort pour
son adversaire alors à faire il a fait 5
il va y avoir quatre ferme
il ferme le jeu ça va échanger la tour
qui va revenir en d1
ouais pour sauver la case f1 alors qu'à
24 fouet fait un tour heureux
il va mettre la tour en d1 peut-être il
a préfet il va préparer des quatre
tranquillement et d'un médecin est
peut-être un des quatre qui peut arriver
ou alors que j'ai trois foulées de voir
des quatre qui arrivent il
prendre peut-être de la tour du cavalier
il va revenir se placer sur sur les
bonnes cases il fait fou prend ou là il
faut prendre quatre ici ouais j'avais
jamais rater une aussi belle et terrible
cette gaffe aux lagaf incroyable ouais
nyan win qui est vraiment pas dans son
assiette un il repart un peu dans ses
travers c'est bien joué surtout preuve
4c quel point f 3 ar il a terriblement
mal joué l'ania l' or la gaffe lagaf est
incroyable 1
gap dennis al zainal et on est reparti à
égalité il reste combien de temps il
reste 20 minutes de jeu toujours
toujours égalité entre les deux hommes
ces bretons un jeu s'est passé je sais
pas si c'est la fatigue il se couche tôt
niall où je sais pas pourquoi il y là il
a vraiment vraiment fait beaucoup de
gaffes ce soir allez va faire ses cinq
peut-être ici ouais ça paraissait
logique et peut-être il va récupérer le
pion il warocqué va faire qu'il réalise
5 j'imagine les français 5
il doit reprendre du cavalier pardon je
raconte un peu n'importe quoi j'ai un
peu moins aussi dépassé par les
événements mais la position il va mettre
le carré en d4
n'at il peut prendre prendre fouet f5
alors il ya les pions qui sont un peu
avancé 1000 à l'oeuf ou de cases
blanches pour couvrir
ouais ça doit aller ça alors il va
échanger
il va échanger en vain il ya peut-être
mettre la dame en effet 6 pour couvrir
un peu son roi très que tu peux pas m'en
faire tour c'est 8 à cause de fou prend
des cinq fait d'amener 6b 4 f 5 7 tours
c8 maintenant il fait fouet cas d'accord
il veut échange dans le cadre prendre en
d4
oui c est presque frais en d4 il aurait
perdu ab c'est donc il va prendre
maintenant il prend g3 à l'esa pardon
des tactiques de partout et affaires
pions prend 1,4 damev karaj la dame
prend 1,3 à la sala il en envoie de
partout là ils jouent bien tactiquement
niall il va réussir encore à gratter b4
et à revenir en hausse est en défense et
mettre les barbelés ça
un qui est maintenant tour des huit très
bien joué il va il va envoyer les pions
maintenant j'arrive à eelv a essuyé un
tour f6 peut-être il fait d'amd cette
e-menace ici va être là d'amendé ce à
quoi excellent excellent et maintenant à
et menace d'armes f6 damage 6 donc il
doit couvrir trois chiens et sûrement b5
alors il faut mettre la marche avant m
et b4 n'y a pas de menace pour les
blancs le pion qui va arriver en b3 ya
toujours pas de menace ou peut-être à 5
il a fait dam des saints qui voulaient
tour f8 en fait c'était ça le truc tour
f6 pardon mais bon il fait b 3 tours f6
b2 et surtout reprend aussi syllabes est
un échec et et puis on prend 1,6 c'est
très bien joué la sqaf et niall dam des
trois hélas le petit dame prend 1,5 qui
fait plaisir à tout on prend des quatre
tout aussi efficace il va faire une
deuxième dame et là il va devoir trouver
un bon coup pour pas se prendre de
problème et ce bon coup c'est peut-être
dame b 6
à ypres en est roi et il va faire dame
f5 dame prend 1,6
c'est aussi très bien joué on arrive à
perdre h6 il va faire un petit coup
d'échec dame prend m6 il va devoir
gagner cette finale n'a les gagnantes
il va faire des échecs qui va revenir
elle est simple à jouer celle avantage
d'avoir une finale comme ça mais bon il
faut quand même se méfier
alors là ce qu'ils cherchent un échange
de dames et il avait d'un match 4 échecs
mais passionnés ils étaient bidonnés pas
être sûr qu'elles gagnent et donc il n'a
pas joué à les a toujours pas des
changes de dames
faut faire gaffe à ne pas se prendre un
père pète mais là il doit pouvoir monter
le roi il va monter là y'a plus d'échec
il va pour faire échec échec
non il a toujours pas de père pète il
n'a toujours pas des changes de dames
non plus
donc il va falloir encore progresser
dames 3 d'anne decis dameuse un an et
reculent avec le roi dame des cinq
échecs
adam g 1 faut faire gaffe continuer à le
ranger 3 parce qu'un dame prend 1,3
pourrait faire patte
je dis ça je dis rien il va falloir se
méfier en tout cas il s'est pas facilité
la vie en rentrant dans cette finale
elle peut elle peut elle peut être
compliqué à gagner
elle peut être compliqué à gagner en
position s'améliore après un allah sans
adversaires à plus damas et là il va y
avoir dame un échec g3 est raide à
machin mat
il voulait aller sur la première rangée
pourra pour éviter les échecs et espérer
une nulle
allez c'est dommage pour anton ans il
aurait pu il aurait pu mieux défendre
il revenait d'un point il reste 15
minutes à jouer et il n'ya là bas qui a
de nouveau une balle de break à la
réellement il a une balle de break la
prendre deux points d'écart à ce moment
là du match
il restera après cette partie une
douzaine de minutes à jouer il restera
cinq partis prendre deux points d'écart
serait un réel avantage
on va voir s'il y arrive
j'avais 4 on va envoyer peut-être du
bessin qu'un jour 4 qui envoyait là ça
joue vraiment sur les deux diagonales ça
l'intérêt d'avoir le double double
enquête au parce que dès qu'on bloque un
fou là avec les noirs on voit qu'on a
pris le parti de bloquer le fou de cases
blanches c'est l'autre fu chi qui
rayonne et c'est ça le truc un peu
pénible alors il va reprendre dans des
cinq tours là où là il ya un problème
avec la dame on peut pas couvrir parce
qu'il ya des quatre et sur dame g5
il ya peut-être un cavalier e 4 qui va
faire très très mal
l'ordinateur affiche + 5 mhz alors là
c'est un piège invisible c'est tombé
comme comme un coup de tonnerre pour le
joueur australien et il abandonne
directement
et oui il sait qu'il est perdant il sait
qu'il a plus trop de temps et là c'est
plus deux pour nihal aniane qui est en
train de s'envoler les amis plus 14
minutes à jouer et le joueur indien qui
fait la différence
la différence est et fait maintenant le
break le break et effet il va falloir
maintenant résister avec les noirs mais
peut-être pas pourquoi pourquoi pas
peut-être même augmenter davantage on a
vu que niall avait l'air d'être très
très à l'aise en bullet ça a l'air
d'être un sacré joueur de parties
rapides et là c'est vrai que il partait
de -1 avec un déficit d'un point et avec
chaque partie y met la pression il
attaque et y gagne mais on a encore
l'impression que ça se passe plutôt pas
mal hein pourrait faire un coup comme kg
catway attaqué le fou qui provoque les
échanges
ça va faire du tour ses sept tours ces
huit ça va s'échanger le long de la
colonne c'est là nul de toute façon pour
nous elle c'est aussi une bonne
opération ainsi la les noirs s'il ya une
partie de plus qui joue du temps qui
coule et qui peut reprendre les blancs à
la prochaine c'est tout bénef
alors maintenant il est peut-être y
avoir un fou à quatre on va juste
vraiment tout est changé et la position
doit être plus ou moins égales même si
c'est le mauvais fou le truc c'est que
le fourrage et 2 peut pas vraiment joué
non plus le fouet le fund blanc qui
repart par là on va vouloir qu'à value8
qui a aidé 6 maintenant là c'est chose
faite le cavalier qui se replacent vers
les quarts est importante
l on peut même faire b 5 à 6 kgs c4 si
on en a envie
maynial qui va se mettre en situation
d'attenté donc là on lui laisse cavale
yeux de fou b5 évidemment si on nous
laisse échanger les fous sont les
échanges et là en plus l'avantagé cette
position là non seulement il n'y a pas
de raison de la perdre mais en plus elle
peut elle peut faire couler pas mal de
temps celle là elle peut elle peut re
faire couler encore trois quatre minutes
de match sans qu'il ne se passe rien
alors la dame des six c'était une
question
voilà j'ai envie de dire que font les
blancs cavalli peu le maître même en
kata et jouer du dam c2a il et il essaye
encore de mettre la pression finalement
yal sarine
il est juste beaucoup plus fort que son
adversaire dans cette cadence et là il
va voir dame ces deux ouais non il est
il est juste beaucoup plus forts n'y a
rien à faire là il ya même même cette
finale l'âge et 4 dames problème de sa
rive
il est juste beaucoup trop au dessus le
joueur le joueur indien dame eux deux
ils menaçaient de me ranger 4 c'est
imparable la lah entonne anton qui est
juste dépassé dame h5 g4 à quoi que
damages 5g cathy l'attaquera puis il
fait juste trois rois g7 et sur dame
prend à sète il va aller faire des
petites carabistouilles qui a aidé deux
cavaliers f3c bien joué et là dessus il
faut trouver le gain
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident en
effet d'un mach 4 dames g4 y répète mais
le carélien le cadre d'accords est sûr
qu'à h3 il veut g4 maintenant et c'est
bien joué très bien joué de la part de
niall qui prend trois points d'avance et
voilà sur le finish à ce qu'on attendait
elle vous aviez au moins six points
comme quoi avec un y allons petite forme
url ça aurait pu faire plus 10 ou +15
avec miral un tout petit peu plus plus
en forme ça aurait pu être très très
très très cher pour anton
j'ai envie de dire heureusement
heureusement pour anton qu'il ait eu à
faire un ami à l'éco plus
je voyais je voyais pas dans quel monde
le joueur australien pouvait résister
mais je m'étais c'est peut-être une des
premières fois où je me planter en
beauté pour ces speech s mais non quand
même pas quand même pas les quarts en
bullet était trop important alors là
l'idée c'est qu'ils veulent et voulait
des cayes point f 5 tours 1 et d4 il est
vraiment affûtés la tactiquement dans
cette fin de match
il en avait gardé sous le pied
est-ce qui va prendre le pion toujours
dangereux en prend un pion devant droit
après un pion c'est un pion il va
sûrement échanger et faire tour et tour
d un il a fait tourner et indirects
là il est pas mal smirnov il ya une même
un pion auquel à ses pions de plus dans
une oreille qui refuse la finale mais
ses pions de plus dans une position
excellente parce que c'est le roi blanc
qui est faible la seule chose c'est b 4
des 5 qui arrive il fait à quatre il
veut à 500 tonnes qui échangent toutes
les pièces c'est bien joué mais va faire
à 5 à 6 j'imagine mais pour essayer de
prendre en c6 et se créent un pion passé
de fou qui va revenir en os 4 c'est un
peu la seule case
à moins que mais a peur de se prendre f5
j'imaginerais par an à 8 du coup là il
est vraiment mal avec les blancs on va
voir
anton qui peut encore espérer en
remportant cette partie est vraiment une
position de ouf la lecavalier qui va
revenir en f4 d'affaires damas 5 pouces
et 6 soit le roi qui se cache
la dame qui revient
ouais mais bon maintenant il doit
chercher des cavaliers f4 dam des trois
essayer de mater dont tellement pas tous
les blancs n'ont pas d'idée un les
blancs sont complètement paralysé et
voilà fouet trois cavaliers ça clôt les
débats après niall qui va sûrement un
petit peu la jouer pour pour faire
tourner la montre il reste suit minute
ça qui peut rester quatre parties
évidemment il tente le petit piège dame
point f de dame reprend f2 évidemment il
a intérêt à nyala à faire durer le
maximum de temps il y arrive plutôt bien
pour le moment
sa défense est plutôt solide mirande
même dans ce genre de petite finale qui
peuvent être truqueuse presse comme
assez évidente à gagner mais bon truc
c'est qu'il ya trop de pions mais bon au
moins tu sais que ça va jouer longtemps
cette histoire le problème c'est que le
roi est pas vraiment dans le carré mais
dans le carré de rien du tout il peut
jouer encore une petite dizaine de
secondes gratter du temps c'est ce
qu'ils souhaitent faire il va gratter le
max il peut jouer encore un coup peut
encore jouer encore jouer un coup il
aurait pu attendre encore 12 secondes le
jeu rapidement pas assez expérimenté le
joueur indien reste plus que sept
minutes
c'est à dire deux ou trois parties là
une victoire une victoire de niall
sarine viendrait clore clore les débats
ont dit 6 minutes 40 ouais c'est ça
c'est ça c'est à peu près on a on a à
peu près le bon prono allez il faut
il faut fermer fermer les portes pour
pour nina sky prend 1,4 dame prend 4 le
gène ce que ça menaçait plusieurs choses
peut-être faire inquiète des 5 1 pour
s'en prendre aux à la tour 3 c'est plus
à risque ont pensé au début m aux grès
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que je
pense pas que il n'ya l'aurait pu faire
un pire match que ça en fait
donc c'est intéressant si le gagne quand
même d'un mec car ils proposent les
changes des dames
la dame qui repart en h5 et geci soit
les dames f3 le retour forcé va voir
échanger dame qui avec quatre épreuves
trois cavaliers f400 en train de de se
terminer ce match les amis c'est une
dernière dernière point de tactique là
pour le joueur indien qui va reprendre
qui va avoir une finale gagnante chez
roy g7 il va même pas s'en prendre aux
pions c'est terrible parce qu'il y avait
un cavalier hafsi ce que j'avais raté
excusez moi mais là il va pouvoir
prendre h3 dans tous les cas tu vas sont
ceux qui ont été condamnés
il va faire g5 maintenant a écrit les
juges et non kg de marché pas et qui
avait plongé 5 attendent et on prend
trois pions prend 2,3 puis on prend g5
comprend puis on prend g5 incroyable
contre tactique du joueur australien qui
trouve le car à l'étranger 5 ici sorti
de nulle part et qui restent dans le
match avec avec ce coup ouais un coup de
coup de trafalgar et maintenant tout
reprend 2,8 et tours d2 d'accord donc
niall qui acceptent de deux filets la
qualité mais qui a qui a beaucoup de jeu
avec avec les noirs c'est avec le fouet
6 est impérial la tour d2 va va aller
chercher les lions aps
c'est vrai que là il défend bien son roi
il n'y a pas vraiment de il n'y a pas de
réseau en réalité qui aura lieu de kayes
france et 3 il est quand même très très
fort niall en l'espace de trois coups
l'aïe a complètement retourné la
situation le roi qui repart en recettes
ya pas un seul échec
il va venir remettre un petit coup
déchets qui va
venir en c3 il va venir soit il fait
qu'elle ait des uns soit il prend 1,4 il
est venu en d1 il va aller chercher à f2
il va prendre 4 il va prendre à deux il
aura beaucoup de beaucoup de matériel y
aura trois pions pour la qualité une
finale complètement gagnante
qu'est-ce qu'il a bien réagi le joueur
indien alors maintenant son adversaire
va essayer d'attaquer les pions par
derrière
il pousse à 5 il va mettre une tour en
payer 8 j'imagine ans il fait b 5e saint
calais ont tant que le réseau de maths
côté côté australie nation a fait retour
à chute au prochain pour menacer pour
menacer tourbe et 7 non il fait tomber
cette direct ce cas le pion aux cinq en
l'air mais après tout rage cette
e-menace pas matin il ya ce satané pions
f7 qui permet au roi de bien se protéger
allez ça envoie à tour à je suis trois
g7 il n'arrive pas à menacer de matha
ils menacent enfin matin a laissé bien
jouer il peut faire ce show que son
adversaire il a échangé rapidement ojla
un échec mais il n'a pas le deuxième en
g8
allez courage 6 3 7 et ce qui à tour
prendre six taureaux 8 y avoir 17 ans il
fait ou rue89 apprend à 8.163 prend
maintenant il ya les pions qui partent
ça va jouer à la course les amis ça va
se jouer à la course
comment est-ce que comment est ce que le
joueur australien va tout défendre le
pion qui va lancer cinq les rois qui
vont venir qui vont venir s'approcher et
or cette histoire là est-ce que c'est
nul ou pas alors là les amis ça doit
être nul cette histoire là parce que les
pions sont très avancés qui n'est pas
facile de s'en emparer
smirnov qui propose là nul mais en cas
de nul ce serait ouais ce serait se
serait match est terminé il peut pas
faire nul de toute façon avec les blancs
il ne peut pas faire un nul
il doit absolument l'emporter il n'a pas
le choix et ce qui peut faire un zoom en
croit ses cinq tours à 5 tours à 4 3 b 5
tours à huit a le truc c'est que dès que
le roi parents bedoya roi b4 il peut
rien faire et leroy b si c'est le roi
qui revient en bessin qu'on n'a pas le
temps de prendre le pion et ça fait
nulle part les pétitions et c'est ce qui
va donner la victoire à niall sarine
il reste 2 minutes 10 de match c'est
impossible de gagner en
en 2 minutes 10 il ya deux points
d'écart en tonnes et éliminer les amis
il est éliminé en quarts de finale du
speech s junior manial sarine une 55 à
l'effet il suffit de jouer cinq ans de
coups là ça suffit
même une partie de 30 40 coups suffira
il lui reste une minute
donc si cela est tombé sur une gaffe tu
peux marquer de points bas non parce que
tu abandonnes pas ludwig il faut mater
il faut mater la même si tu gagnes une
tour en 1 il faut mater et autant te
dire que ma tête en moins de 40 coups
des joueurs de ce niveau là il faut se
lever de bonne heure
surtout quand la position est déjà
complètement foutu ouais bah c'est déjà
foutu en plus il réfléchit quelques
secondes donc là chaque seconde qui a
réfléchi et évidemment c'est des coups
en moins à jouer pour niall est là à
chaque fois et je réutilise de toute
façon à une petite seconde à chaque coup
et la très bientôt on va rentrer dans le
domaine du match terminé
mathématiquement 40 secondes il reste il
y aurait ceux dits coup à jouer à niall
ci se fait pas mal tandis que ça va
passer
ça a l'air de bien se passer là qui
prend ses quatre ça a l'air sympa tu en
prends ses quatre tours france et 4
après tu fais à 5h06 je propose ça c'est
pas par rapport
c'est pas parce que c'est le meilleur
coup hein c'est juste parce que ça fait
face a fait jouer beaucoup de coups en
fait il a fait à 5,26 secondes il reste
combien de temps dans le match il reste
20 et 21 secondes
allez il suffit de jouer deux coups là
il finit par faire qui les prend ses
quatre fous prend ses quatre et ça y est
c'est mathématiquement terminée les amis
niall qui s'impose dans ce match et qui
était vraiment beaucoup plus forts en
bulles est c'est ça qui a fait qui a
fait la diff petite forme pour niall
mais ça suffira il faudra qu'il élève
son niveau de juin par nom par contre
voilà ça y est le match est
officiellement
terminé le favori l'a emporté c'est une
des premières fois où avec un favori je
suis quasiment sûre qui gagne on passe
proche de la correctionnelle mais je
garde sur les sur les gros favoris je
garde
je dois jouer à être à peut-être 39
bonnes prédictions sur 40 matchs je
garde je garde le strict
après j'aurais bien aimé avoir quand
même là un match qui dure une petite 15h
d'or de plus histoire d'être bien sûr
quand même je trouve qu'on n'est pas sûr
à 100% entre hier et aujourd'hui on
n'est pas sûr à 100% que le meilleur et
gagner et ça ça m'embête un petit peu
honnêtement le 1 sur 40 c'était un match
de duda contre car yakine mais là on est
sûr du tout et franchement peu déçu d'un
match un peu trop court à mon goût qui
aurait mérité qui aurait mérité quelques
dizaines d'heures de plus de jeu pour
être bien sûr le match va s'arrêter là
m la pub comme ça on pourra faire le
switch rapidement bonne idée ça ça ne
perd pas de temps bon c'est nul niall
sarine qui sait pas qui a plus de temps
mais c'est terminé
alors pour match terminé les gars du
coup bravo hani al zain qui se qualifie
on verra quand ils jouent en demi-finale
contre ait martirossian s'il a fixé la
demi finale a lieu avec tous ces
scandales à gauche à droite avec ques
les faux et cetera on verra bien où ça
nous mène où on va se retrouver tout de
suite on va se faire un peu de blitz je
vais je vais essayer après
malheureusement tous et speechless me
flingue le cerveau mais on va essayer d'
un peu blitz et donc je vous dis tu en
as je vais m je met le truc je met le
bon truc pour qu'on fasse le switch
j'avais mon truc bien en plus on va
avoir les nouveaux clips
allez c'est parti ces parts et les mecs
gens voient leur aide dans dans quelques